[Musique]
Gaspar Glanz, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Serview.
Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous
vous pouvez vous présenter succintement
?
Je m'appelle Gaspar Glanz. Je suis né à
Strasbourg en 1987.
Euh donc j'ai été conçu quand les
liquidateurs de Chernoby étaient sur le
toit du récteur.
[Musique]
J'y ai grandi, j'y ai fait ma scolarité
dans l'école publique jusqu'à 18 ans. À
la suite de quoi, je suis parti en Renn
faire mes études universitaires. Je les
ai terminé à Strasbourg et j'ai lancé
Taranis en société avec des potes à moi
à Renn en 2011. On s'est rapidement
rendu compte qu'une SRL en France est un
peu compliqué. Du coup, on a changé de
technique et bah on est toujours là
aujourd'hui, même si c'est plus la même
équipe que celle qui était là au départ.
Et voilà, entre-temps, j'ai fait pas mal
de reportages beaucoup en France,
quelques-uns en Europe, en Allemagne,
sur le la trace des réfugiés quand il y
avait la crise en 2015, donc pas mal en
Europe de l'Est. Et euh voilà
pourquoi avoir choisi cette profession ?
Euh mon père est enfin était photographe
parce que il a changé de métier
entre-temps. Donc j'ai un peu grandi
dans un studio photo euh argentique à
l'époque et il faisait pas de
l'actualité mais du coup la photo
c'était un peu un truc qui était déjà
chez moi à la base. et j'ai un peu je me
suis un peu rapproché du milieu
politique quand j'étais au collège et au
lycée d'abord ensuite à l'université
en étant appliqué à l'époque à l'Union
nationale lycéenne à l'époque du CPE et
de ces mouvements sociaux là et bah
c'est un peu fait de lien entre les deux
quand je suis arrivé à l'université Ren
2, c'est que il y avait ces âgés
monstrueuses avec 6500 étudiants, des
grèves qui duraient un semestre entier
et cetera. Il y avait enfin on est à une
époque où il y a pas encore Facebook, il
y a pas encore Twitter et cetera. il y
avait que YouTube et euh et du coup, il
fallait un petit peu témoigner de de ce
qui était décidé pour les autres
étudiants qui venaient pas aux
assemblées générales ou même pour les
autres qui regardaient ce qui se passait
à Renn, une ville qui était un peu une
référence en France pour pour
l'évouement sociaux à l'époque. Et du
coup, bah j'ai commencé par filmer
les assemblées générales, faire un
espèce de site qui qui rassemblait les
décisions qui avaient été prises en
assemblée générale à Renn euh puisquon
avait quand même trois par semaine. Je
filmais les votes parce qu'en fait il y
avait une espèce de remise en question
de la réalité enfin le comptage des
votes puisque c'était des votes à main
levé sur une foule immense. Donc de
filmer de d'un point élevé, ça
permettait aux gens de constater que le
vote était correct. Ça un peu commencé
comme ça et puis forcément à Renn il se
passait beaucoup de choses et euh donc
là on est avant les années 2010. Donc
quand j'ai fini mes études et que je me
suis demandé ce que je devais faire,
j'ai un peu regardé ce que je savais
faire de mieux et puis ben c'était le
journalisme. Voilà. En gros, vous n'avez
pas de carte de presse.
Non. Alors, ça c'est pour une raison qui
est administrative
et c'est fatiguant, mais c'est la
réalité de la complexité de
l'administration française parce que ça
fait techniquement et à 100 %
économiquement que 12 ans maintenant que
je suis journaliste. Et bah, c'est
fatiguant mais c'est comme ça quoi.
Alors, je vais l'avoir bientôt. J'ai pas
fini la c'est j'ai perdu une bataille
mais j'ai pas perdu la guerre. Je l'ai
pas eu en tant que journaliste
indépendant euh pour des raisons
vraiment purement euh juridiques,
bizarres, enfin de clôture d'une SARL
justement qui était pas correct, qui
était pas effectué correctement par
rapport au dossier machin. Enfin, ça me
fatigue. Voilà. Mais c'est comme ça.
Comment vous allez avoir cette carte de
presse ? Alors,
et ben du coup, je vais travailler avec
un statut, enfin je vais être payé avec
un statut qui me permettra d'être
reconnu comme journaliste au sens de la
loi. Et donc, normalement, dans 3 mois,
je devrais enfin avoir cette carte.
C'est quoi la loi pour être journaliste
pour avoir une carte de presse ? Alors
franchement, je pense qu'il faut poser
cette question à quelqu'un qui s'y
connaît parce que même en tant que
journaliste, j'ai pas vraiment compris
d'avoir une carte de presse pour être
journaliste.
Non, justement, j'ai ramené les papiers
que j'adore montrer à la police quand il
m'embête avec ça. Et en gros, la
dernière loi en question, journal de la
République française, pardon, euh c'est
la loi9 290 du 10 avril 2019 visant à
renforcer et à maintenir le maintien de
l'ordre dans public lors des
manifestations.
Et euh Ah non, ça c'est pour le ça c'est
pour l'histoire du masque à gaz, pardon.
Euh parce qu'il y en a il y a d'autres.
Non, la carte de presse n'est pas
obligatoire pour être journaliste en
France. Ça c'est un article de la FP qui
a été écrit euh juste après ma garde à
vue d'avril 2019. Voilà, donc vous
pouvez le retrouver sur AFP factuel.
Non, la carte de presse n'est pas
obligatoire pour la jouriste en France
et c'est expliqué et illustré. Quand
quand vous montrez ça aux forces de
l'ordre, qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Parce
que les forces de l'ordre,
ça dépend lesquelles,
c'est-à-dire
bah ça dépend de leurs intentions. Si un
moment ils savent pas et que bon, ils
sont un peu perdus, tu arrives à un
checkpoint, ils se disent "C'est qui
ceuxl avec leur gros sac et leur casque
Il y a moyen de peut-être leur expliquer
s'ils sont de bonne humeur. Si dès que
tu es arrivé au bout du boulevard, ils
t'ont vu, ils se sont dit journaliste
égal is gauchiste, tu passeras pas.
Voilà, tu peux leur montrer les papiers,
ils s'en foutent. C'est pareil. Voilà.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils disent ?
Ah, ça dépend. On a de tout. Euh
qu'est-ce qu'ils disent ? Quelles sont
les excuses pour nous empêcher de passer
ou qu'est-ce qu'ils disent à quel moment
? Au moment où on arrive à check.
Donc pour eux, pas de carte de presse
égale pas journaliste égale mitard.
C'est ça.
Alors là, il y a un truc qui est encore
plus compliqué, c'est qu'il y a eu la
le schéma de
il y a eu la PPL sécurité globale qui
est passé cet automne. Donc maintenant,
il y a encore ce débat où maintenant il
croit vraiment que c'est bon, c'est
passé, c'est voté, tu as pas de carte de
presse, tu tu peux pas. Et en plus même
ceux qui auraient une carte de presse ne
pourraient pas filmer la police, ce qui
est absolument pas vrai puisque ce qui a
été voté avec la PPL sécurité globale,
c'est l'intention. Ça veut dire que il
ça change absolument rien sur la manière
de de filmer et d'avoir le droit de
filmer la police sur l'espace public. Ce
qui est ce qui change, c'est ce qu'on
fait avec.
C'est l'intention.
C'est l'intention. Et mais ça ne change
absolument pas le fait qu'on a
parfaitement le droit, toi, moi
journaliste ou pas, de filmer la police
sur l'espace public, y compris leur
visage, y compris leur matricule. Enfin,
ça n'a pas changé en fait. Mais à cause
de de tout le débat de tout le le de
tous les passages de Darmanin à la télé
et cetera, ben on est arrivé à une
situation maintenant la police croit que
euh on a carrément plus le droit de les
filmer quoi. Donc euh c'est extrêmement
compliqué parce que il y a pas grand
monde qui a qui a compris le sens de des
lois qui définissent tout ça et euh et
encore moins les agents de police quoi.
Nous, on a on a décidé de de te si je
peux me permettre, de te faire On a
décidé de te faire venir.
Hm hm. parce queon trouve que tu fais un
très bon boulot et et que et que tu es
tu as la capacité de nous procurer le
don d'ubiquité,
de se déplacer
d'un coup comme ça un claquement de
doigt, d'être nos yeux et nos oreilles
et on on t'a vu te faire massacrer
pendant certaines manifestations
et on voudrait que tu nous décrives
comment ça se passe, l'ambiance, quels
sont les dispositifs de sécurité,
la prise de température sur place, ça
c'est c'est une montée en puissance.
C'est un dispositif qui crée ça. Toutes
ces violences quand on a vu des gens se
faire balafrer, se faire arracher des
joues, se faire arracher des yeux, se
faire arracher des mains, qu'est-ce qui
crée ça ? C'est c'est une mauvaise
communication entre les forces de
l'ordre, les manifestants et
l'agressivité des manifestants c'est
quoi ?
Ça a changé. Euh justement, on dit "J'ai
pas encore la carte de presse." Quand
j'ai commencé à travailler, c'était même
pas c'était encore Jacques Chirac qui
était président. Donc j'ai vu passer
Sarco, j'ai vu passer Hollande, Vals
aussi, Cassener, même si c'était pas
président. Mais euh ça a beaucoup
changé. Euh ça paraît paradoxal
aujourd'hui mais c'était plus câble sous
Sarco. Mais tout a changé en fait. Ça
veut dire que tu regardes des vidéos de
de manifestation en 2007, notamment même
le soir de son élection, il y en avait
déjà. ça même durer 2 jours. Euh les
manifestants sont pas masqués, ils sont
pas habillés en noir. Euh ils ont leur
habit tous les jours, ils ont leur sac
d'école, euh ils sont reconnaissables à
500 km. Enfin, c'est il y a il y a pas
il y a un bloc dans le sens qu'on qu'on
a aujourd'hui dans une manifestation
quand on voit un black block, mais ils
sont pas en black block. On on peut
considérer qu'en France, d'après ce que
j'ai observé, mais après c'est mon
analyse personnelle, mais le le black
block
est devenu quelque chose en France au
sens politique du terme en 2009 au
moment du sommet de l'OTAN à Strasbourg
justement quand la France est rentrée
dans l'OTAN avec Nicolas Sarkozi. C'est
la première fois en fait qu'on a vu un
black block en France mais c'était pas
des Français
c'était quoi ? Des Allemands ?
C'était des Allemands principalement. Il
y avait des Italiens, il y avait il y
avait des Polonais, il y avait enfin
voilà, il y avait un peu toute l'Europe.
Mais le ça a été assez chaud. C'était la
première venue de Barack Obama en Europe
euh notamment. Euh ça a été une bah ça a
été une manif très très particulière
mais c'est la première fois que les
Français en fait qui étaient d'ailleurs
en mouvement social euh à l'université,
c'était contre la loi de responsabilité
des universités de Valérie PCR en 2009.
Et donc ils étaient en mouvement social,
il y avait des blocages dans les
universités. Donc quand le mouvement
social quand le sommet de l'OTAN est
arrivé en avril, les étudiants, ils
étaient déjà enfin ils avaient le temps
de pouvoir se rendre à Strasbourg au
sommet de l'OTAN. Donc ils s sont allés
et ils ont découvert, il y avait des
curdes aussi, communauté assez
importante à Strasbourg. Donc il y a eu
cette manif explosive
quand les Français sont arrivés sur le
camp, ça a duré 3 jours, donc il y avait
une espèce de camping machin. Ils ont
découvert le bloc Hambourg, le bloc
Francfort, le bloc Berlin organisé avec
des des chiottes sèches machin que ça. À
ce moment-là, notre annon ça existe pas.
Donc les Français ont découvert ça à ce
moment-là et ça se voyait. Enfin, ils
prenaient des notes et quand ils ont ils
ont vu les manifestations, ça a été la
même chose. Il a fallu attendre
Notredame des Landes pour qu'on observe.
Là, je parle du côté manifestant mais
pour qu'on observe ce genre de
méthodologie,
c'est pas vraiment manifque c'était dans
les dans les champs à notre sauf quand
c'était à Nant et qu'il y avait des
manifes dans les rues, notamment les
manifes de 2012 si je me trompe pas,
février 2012, 22 février 2012 où je me
suis pris ma première grenade d'ailleurs
euh des enklantes et
euh euh où on a observé pour la première
fois, on va dire, technique de de black
block concret équipé, banderoll renforcé
et cetera dans une ville à Nantes.
Voilà, ça c'est février 2012. Euh,
qu'est-ce que tuentends par équiper ?
Habé en noir avec des fringues
changeable. Je vais pas te donner toutes
les méthodes du bloc, mais d'une manière
à ce que si ils sont filmés en train de
faire des actions, on puisse pas les
identifier après coup. Voilà, c'est le
principe déplacement bloc, c'est
déplacement en équipe, une
communication, des des binôes, des
choses comme ça. Mais ça ça n'existait
pas en France. C'est un peu apparu, on
va dire, à l'ouest en Bretagne moment,
notre des landes. Et c'est quand on
regarde le début de de la loi travail
des manifestations contre la loi travail
en 2016 à Paris, c'est c'est
principalement encore des jeunes, des
lycéens, des étudiants et il y a pas
encore cette méthode qui arrive tout de
suite. Elle arrive en 2017. Euh pourquoi
elle arrive en 2017 ? Parce qu'il y a le
sommet du juveur à Hambourg. Et là, ça a
été un déclic au niveau du au niveau
manifestant, je parle. C'est-à-dire que
on a vraiment pu constater, bon déjà
c'était c'était quelque chose le je de
rebourg mais il y avait vraiment
beaucoup de français. C'était le
Excuse-moi, je vais juste me moucher
mais je ne suis un petit peu allergic au
pollen.
Merci. Et donc à Hambourg
les manifestants français qui devaient
représenter le premier contingent
étranger euh parce que également ils
étaient en mouvement social. en 2017, je
sais plus ce que c'était mais c'était
avant le l'élection non c'était en
juillet, donc c'était juste après
l'élection de de Macron. Euh il devait y
avoir entre
400 et 500 peut-être plus de de Français
dans la manif. les premiers
contingentsents étrangers et là le le
bloc allemand a été très impressionnant,
très très organisé surtout la police
allemande ne se comporte absolument pas
comme la police française. C'est déjà
ils sont pas armés de la même manière,
ils sont pas équipés de la même manière,
ils se déplacent pas de la même manière,
ils se ils arrêtent pas les gens de la
même manière pour les mêmes raisons. Euh
en général, ils lui mettent une grosse
claque sur le moment puis il le laisse
traîner et puis voilà, c'est réglé quoi.
Mais
la manière dont la police a géré la
manifestation du Gevur Deembourg a
beaucoup appris aux manifestants
français qui était le plus impliqués, on
va dire dans dans les manif. Quand ils
sont rentrés à Paris, ça s'est senti
immédiatement que le le G20 de Hambourg
avait laissé des traces dans
l'organisation. Après comme c'est des
gens qui n de tout le pays, ça s'est
probablement aussi senti à Lille, à
Rennes, à Nantes, dans les villes qui
sont à Toulouse, dans les villes qui
sont classiquement sociologiquement plus
active quoi. Au niveau de la police, ce
qui a changé, bah bon déjà Nicolas
Sarkozi, il a il a donné une espèce de
confiance dans la violence et on va dire
le je sais pas comment le définir mais
l'impunité de la police. Moi, je suis
allé à GPN de nombreuses fois. Euh, j'ai
jamais eu de procès quoi.
IGPN qui veut dire
hein
qui me
qui veut dire IGPN l'abréviation ça veut
dire
inspection générale de la police
nationale. Voilà. Mais enfin, j'y suis
allé là encore bah on parlait de la
grenade de du 5 décembre 2019. Euh
j'ai euh quatre plots là, trois plots
dans le téléphone, un ici, deux dans ma
enfin je me suis pris les tr/4 de la
grenade, elle a explosé à mes pieds. Et
euh euh 17 jours dit par un médecin
légiste, euh pas par mon médecin ou quoi
que ce soit machin que ça donc euh
machin la plainte et cetera. Je suis
allé voir le GPN un mois après, ils ont
identifié le tireur en 3 jours parce que
tout simplement celui-ci, il avait frimé
quand il est revenu à la caserne. Ouais,
j'ai shooté Glanz.
Ça c'était un mois après le shoot. On
est donc en janvier 2020. Aujourd'hui,
on est en mai 2021. J'ai aucune nouvelle
de ça.
Euh et c'est juste une fois où je suis
allé à les GPN. Il y en a eu 5 ou six de
en 6 ans. Donc à un moment, moi je passe
en procès.
Revenons avant avant revenons revenons
sur l'évolution de la violence.
Oui.
Donc elle elle a eu d'abord une forme
d'impunité. Elle a senti une forme
d'impunité, ce qui a fait qu'elle est
elle est devenue plus plus offensive
dans sa manière d'agir. Ensuite, c'est
pas c'est pas les manifestants qui
devenir aussi plus offensif.
Il y a pas il y a pas eu a Est-ce que
c'est les manifestants qui ont changé
d'abord ? Oui,
oui, ça c'est clair. Mais la manière
dont la police s'est adapté clairement
c'est c'est enfin c'est c'était pas
c'était pas la bonne manière dans le
sens où ça aggravé la situation parce
que en étant violente de cette manière
avec des armes disproportionnées sur des
gamins et cetera, ça allait pas
améliorer la situation quoi. Quand j'ai
fait des manif, je suis désolé de
comparer avec l'Allemagne mais c'est
Julien de Strasbourg donc bon c'est
logique, je suis allé plein de fois mais
à un moment ils ont des manifes où il y
a des situations qui sont 50 fois pire
que qu'en France. genre
euh genre des manifes antifascistes en
Allemagne, c'est pas le même niveau
qu'en France, quoi. Ils ont peut-être un
historique, mais ils ont aussi des
antifascistes à un niveau euh
comparable, quoi. Et euh et du coup,
quand il y a des manifs en Allemagne,
mais ils ont pas de grenade à Rambourg,
par exemple, si puisque c'était là où
j'étais, euh aucune grenade explosive et
ils nous ont tiré du lacrymogène deux
fois dessus. Euh c'était à la toute fin
du pire jour, à 2h du matin quand ils en
avaient marre à qui voulaient rentrer à
l'hôtel. euh sur les dernières personnes
qui étaient là, on a eu un peu de mais
c'est tout. Autant ils nous ont arrosé
avec je sais pas combien de de canons à
eau machin quand ils y vont à la
matraque, ils y vont, ils poussent les
gens et cetera. Mais mais c'est
physique, c'est c'est la et surtout ça
c'est la grosse différence entre la
police allemande et la police française.
Et c'est un des problèmes qui se sent
aujourd'hui avec l'allemand, c'est que
la police française nasce les gens, elle
les enferme des heures, ce qui va pas
calmer une situation qui est ruptive
quoi. Les Allemands lèchent toujours une
po de de sortie. Il y a toujours une rue
où on peut s'en aller. Il y a toujours
un trou où on peut partir et sans comme
en France être fouillé, contrôlé où on a
une amende 235 € pour être sorti machin,
une amend 235 € pour un rassemblement
qui était interdit et cetera. Enfin,
c'est en Allemagne si tu peux partir, tu
tu peux y aller. Voilà, tu veux partir,
tu peux t'en aller. Et et cette espèce
de désescalade constante, bah ça marche
en fait. C'est et du coup quand on
observe, je compare avec la France
puisque on essaie d'avoir un élément de
comparaison euh en France il nas après
avoir balancé des grenades, avoir gazé
tout le monde, donc les gens ils sont
ils ont les yeux explosés, ils ont la
gorge défoncée, ils savent qu'ils vont
prendre des amendes, ils savent pas
combien de temps ils vont rester
enfermés, le couvre-feu arrive, machin
enfin cette espèce de tension qui monte
va frustrer les gens. Alors s'il
s'énervent pas tout de suite, ils vont
la prochaine fois à la manif suivante.
Mais c'est pas du tout une stratégie de
la désescalade. Et et du coup la la
police a d'abord laisser tomber cette
stratégie de des escalades offensif et
cetera. Ensuite, il y a une autre
Abdand. Alors ça c'est compliqué à
comparer avec le reste parce que c'était
la gendarmerie. À notre il y avait pas
de policiers et c'est pas un mystère
mais les gendarmes et la police c'est
pas la même chose quoi. C'est je vais
pas jeter des fleurs sur la gendarmerie
font des conneries aussi hein. Mais
concrètement c'est clairement pas la
même chose. Enfin c'est pas pareil. J'ai
je juste donner un exemple pour
illustrer mais quand on a comme la
dernière fois samedi la manife
proalestinienne à Barb si on a des
checkpoint avec des CRS des checkpoints
avec la compagnie de sécurité et
d'intervention et des checkpoints avec
les gendarmes on va choisir les
gendarmes quoi pour passer parce que eux
au moins on peut leur parler leur
montrer la loi et voilà c'est pas
journaliste tuas la carte de presse n
dégage enfin c'est voilà
en terme en terme de violence
de voir tout ça toi sur le terrain au
cœur au cœur de de cette révolte de voir
ce sang. Est-ce que ça a laissé des des
séquelles en toi ? Alors moi ça m'est
pas arrivé mais c'est arrivé à un membre
de mon équipe. Alors c'était pas
vraiment le les le sang et tout. Faut
savoir quand on est en manif enfin même
sur des événements
on a beaucoup d'adrénaline. Donc c'est
pas c'est pas le sur le moment c'est pas
là que tu vas ressentir des si tu prends
une grenade oui tu vas le sentir passer.
Mais si tu vois quelque chose de
traumatisant, possiblement enfin moi en
tout cas c'est pas sur le moment que ça
va sortir sur le moment tu es concentré,
tu potentiellement tu vas te faire tirer
dessus aussi. Donc ça peut t'arriver, tu
tu penses plutôt mer "Merde, ça aurait
pu être moi." Et mais il y a pas de au
contraire, on essaie de bien cadrer, de
pas avoir le visage du de la personne
s'il est dessus, de de d'avoir la
blessure, de enfin je sais pas, ça va
très vite tout ça en plus. Donc il y a
plein de gens autour, donc on reste
concentré sur notre travail mais on
pense pas à ça. Ce qui a traumatisé un
de mes collègues et et ce qui
potentiellement je pense m'a mis un coup
aussi c'est les camp de réfugié beaucoup
plus. Euh ça ça n'a rien à voir en terme
de alors je sais pas si ça dépend des
gens. Peut-être qu'il y en a qui sont
plus traumatisés par les manifes que par
la la misère ou ou la souffrance. Mais
Calé, la jungle de Calé,
je pense pas que quelqu'un qui un
journaliste ou même un humanitaire ou un
français en fait qui soit peut-être même
un vélic qui soit rentré dans la jungle
et qui l' visité qui a parlé à des gens
en sortin d'emme quoi. Genre
j'ai pas fait de guerre dans ma vie. Je
suis pas allé en Syrie, je suis pas allé
en Irak, j'ai pas fait de ter guerre, je
suis pas allé en Afghanistan, je suis
pas un journaliste de guerre. Mais ce
que étant donné que la plupart des
réfugiés qui étaient dans la jungle de
Calé venaient de pays en guerre et que
la situation était vraiment dégueulasse,
je vais pas la résumer, je pense que ça
a déjà été fait. si si
ça ressemblait à quoi ?
Ça donnait une ambiance où on avait un
peu l'impression d'y être quoi. Euh je
me suis retrouvé à un moment avec Louis
V qui le photographe qui rentrait
justement de Ziri avec ses photos. On
était on était parmi les seules
journalistes qui rentraient la nuit dans
la jungle. On était dans un espèce de
une espèce de taverne qui était
construite en palette euh avec des
migrants syriens qui avaient fui la
Syrie puisque justement c'était la
guerre. Et euh et Louis a sorti ses
photos et c'était incroyable parce qu'en
fait les mecs enfin c'était 15 km à côté
de chez eux en fait et donc il ah c'est
ce village cette route je l'ai déjà pris
pour machin et cetera et il y avait
trois mecs au bout de la table qui
regardaient leurs chaussures et qui
parlaient pas et cetera et comme tu es
dans un camp de réfugié il est 2h du
matin tu as 5000 € de matos sur toi on
on les connaissait les mecs on leur
faisait confiance mais tu es toujours
sur tes gardes quoi. Il y a il y a il y
a pas de loi dans cet endroit quoi. Et
et on se disait bon là ça c'est bizarre
tout le monde est armé tout le monde a
un couteau là-dedans. Enfin, ça peut
partir en couille assez vite et cetera.
Euh pour avoir traîné dans la rue de la
soifen, au moins, ils sont pas bourrés,
donc c'est moins dangereux. Mais ouais.
Donc les mecs qui étaient au bout de la
table en fait, c'était des gars du
régime syrien. Et quand on comprenait
pas l'arabe, donc on savait pas ce qu'il
se disait, on parlait anglais avec les
réfugiés, mais ils étaient très contents
de voir les photos, il parlaient de tout
ça, mais en fait les gars au bout, ils
avaient fui le même coin mais ils
étaient pas du même camp quoi. Et donc,
on discutait avec des rebelles en fait
et c'était en fait la guerre, on était à
15000 km d'elle mais elle était à table
avec nous quoi. Et c'est ça, c'est fait
partie des des moments cool qu'on qu'on
a qu'on a vécu.
euh avec Louis notamment, on est parti
en 2015 au moment de la crise des
réfugiés sur bah quand il y a des
milliers de réfugiés qui arrivaient de
Grèce qui remontaient en Europe. On est
parti avec la voiture de sa mamie, une
vieille 306 toute pourave. On a roulé
jusqu'au milieu de la Serbie à peu près
en 2 jours jusqu'à ce que on ait peur
qu'elle explose et bah on agrippé un peu
le la colonne de réfugiés puis on l'a
remonté jusque jusqu'en France quoi.
Donc on a fait les frontières en fait la
frontière entre la Serbie et la Hongrie,
la frontière entre l'Hongrie et
l'Autriche la frontière entre l'Autriche
et l'Allemagne et euh
je je te je te recentre un peu. Revenons
sur nos violences policières en magique.
Oui pardon. Non mais t'inquiète, on aura
le temps de revenir.
C'est juste que oui, je revenais,
c'était sur le le la jungle de Calé. En
fait,
tuas le cerveau qui tourne très très
vite tout le temps. Non,
c'est la jungle de Calé. J'ai un exemple
assez intéressant, c'est en général les
policiers quand les CRS quand ils se
déplacent sur un sur un d'après ce que
j'ai compris he, je suis pas du tout
expert policier euh mais quand ils se
déplacent sur un sur un environnement en
compagnie, ils y restent une semaine, 10
jours, 12 jours. Quand ils allaient à
Calé, il restaient 4 jours, pas un de
plus. Et en général, c'était vachement
intéressant parce que ça se voyait s'il
venaient d'arriver ou s'ils allaient
partir. Il y avait toujours une une
espèce de longue colonne de policiers
placés tous les 3 m à l'entrée de la
jungle pour protéger un peu
l'environnement de je sais pas quoi. Il
y avait une autoroute à côté, ils
essayaient de les mecs essayaient de
monter dans les camions, donc ils
essaient d'empêcher l'accès au camion.
Les premiers jours, c'est rest quand ils
venaient d'arriver, ils étaient derrière
leur boucliers mais levés à hauteur de
la tête. Ils avaient peur des gens. Les
mecs, il venaient de marcher 15 km pour
aller faire les courses. Il revenait
avec des sachets, ils les regardait
comme des OVNIS. Genre mais qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont quoi ? Au bout de 4 jours,
les flics, ils étaient posés sur leur
bouclier comme ça, complètement blasé et
il savaiit plus pourquoi ils étaient là
en 4 jours. Et il y a une autre fois où
on est arrivé à caler, c'était encore
avec Louis d'ailleurs, on a voulu,
c'était une opération, c'est le plus
gros fail de ma carrière et j'ai pas
honte de le raconter parce qu'il faut
que ça serve d'exemple pour les autres.
On a voulu aller à Calé sans que les
flics le sachent, c'est-à-dire sans que
ils puissent savoir qu'on est là pour
éviter que il ne fasse pas une
évacuation parce qu'on était là, parce
qu'on venait avec une équipe un peu
conséquente. Donc on a réservé une
voiture à un autre nom, on a réservé un
hôtel à un autre nom avec une autre
carte bancaire machin. Enfin, on a
contrôlé le truc, on a on a coupé nos
téléphones, on a on a pris des
téléphones dans des tabac machin à
Barbess et cetera. Enfin vraiment
l'opération commando James Bond et tout,
on a roulé depuis Paris, on s'est pas
arrêté et cetera. On n pas fait le plein
au milieu d'une aire d'autoroute sous
les caméras comme il faut.
On arrive à l'hôtel à Calé,
il y avait cinq compagnies de CRS sur le
parking et s'il y avait que des CRS dans
l'hôtel.
Je te raconte pas. Quand on est arrivé à
la caisse, il y avait un CRS qui était
posé en comme ça en faction à côté de la
caisse hier et nous on arrive avec nos
sacs avec les casques télé, les masques
à gaz, les machins et il nous a regardé
genre mais c'est quoi ça ? Et et comme
il était comme il était là
à côté de la caissière, je lui ai
demandé s'il faisait le ménage aussi
mais il il avait pas il était pas trop
d'humeur et du coup il a pas répondu.
Est-ce que ça t'a Je te coupe pardon, on
reviendra sur ça juste après. Est-ce que
ça t'est déjà arrivé de d'avoir une
discussion à bâton rompu ? Bah ce
jour-là, oui. Euh ce soir-là, euh bah en
fait, on a filmé puis on est retourné à
l'hôtel, on a monté euh Louis traitait
ses photos, moi je je montais je montais
mes vidéos et on entendait du bruit. Et
en fait,
quel type ?
Euh la fête, tout le couloir, c'était
des flics. Je dirais pas quel compagnie
c'est comme ça j'aurais pas de problème.
Mais mais c'est la vérité, il y a des
témoins, on était trois donc je il y a
des gens qui pourront confirmer mes dir
mais c'était un sacré bordel. Il y avait
de la musique. Tu sentais que ça passait
dans le couloir. Il était plus de 23h30
machin dans un hôtel. Normalement, c'est
du coup, on ouvre la porte.
La porte de juste en face de la chambre
de juste en face de nous était ouverte
et il y avait genre cinq bouteilles de
Polyakov par terre à moitié vide et il
en voilà, c'était la tef quoi. Voilà,
vraiment c'était la TF. Ils ont le droit
de faire la fête tout le monde. Bref, du
coup on se dit voilà c'est trop beau,
faut qu'on aille fumer une clope pour
pour voir ce que ça donne quoi. On va
pas sortir les caméras, chacun a droit
sa vie privée ça. Enfin voilà, chacun a
droit à sa vie privée. Tu travailles
pas, tu travailles pas mais on est sorti
pour pour discuter quoi. Alors il y
avait plusieurs profils. Il y avait ceux
qui tout de suite dès qu'ils ont compris
qu'on était journaliste, qu'on voilà
qu'on était pas policier et cetera, tout
de suite ils essayaient de nous taquiner
machin. Ouais machin. Bon cela c'était
pas la peine de discuter. Il y avait
ceux qui étaient un peu curieux. Ouais.
C'est comment votre métier ? Ils
essayaient de savoir si d'être
journaliste c'était pas mieux que d'être
policier. En fait, ils étaient assez
jeunes. Ils avaient c'était c'était des
CRS, ils devaient avoir, ils étaient
plus jeunes que nous, donc je sais pas
20 22 23 24 25 ans quoi. Et ouais.
Alors, comment ça comment ça se passe ?
Comment vous travaillez ? Enfin, curieux
mais sans plus.
En train de dire que je pose des
questions de CRS là.
Non, j'ai pas dit ça, pas du tout. Mais
et il y en avait un qui lui par contre
ça été assez intéressant parce que il
était curieux et du coup il est resté,
on a pu discuter et ah [__] il y a une
scène, je suis obligé de la raconter
parce que c'était vraiment trop beau.
Mais ils ont voulu nous provoquer et du
coup je vais la raconter. De toute
façon, c'était en 2017 donc ça va ça
remonte mais euh donc il y avait à peu
près 5 si CRS dehors. Ils étaient en
civil, ils travaillaient pas. Nous on
était là, on fumait des clops, on
discutait et il y en a un qui sort en
tenue de CRS avec une bouteille de vin à
la main. Mais il était il était bien. Et
il prend la camenette de CRS et il le
fait en nous regardant, sachant
pertinemment qui on est parce qu'avant
il avait discuté avec nous et en disant
"C'est que les gars on va en
discothèque, vous montez avec moi." Il
boit un gros coup, il prend le volant et
il prend la camionnette et il part et
cetera. C'était juste pour nous prouver
qu'il faisait ce qu'il voulait en fait.
Et les autres ils étaient, il y en avait
qui rigolaient, il y en avait qui [__]
mais quel con, mais pourquoi il fait ça
devant eux et tout machin. On l'a pas
raconté mais je suis obligé de le faire
aujourd'hui. Et euh et donc du coup
l'autre était là, il est resté, il a
discuté et il nous disait qu'il avait
une femme, une petite fille et qu'il
avait six guns différents chez lui et
genre 800 munitions ou un truc comme ça.
Et il y avait pas encore le
c'était pas de l'esbrouff ? Non
non non non. Il était il était concret.
Il nous dit, il nous disait "Oui, moi je
j'aime bien les armes, je tire beaucoup
machin passionné quoi." Et mais je lui
disais un moment concrètement pourquoi
?
Enfin, tu as peur de
du tir sportif.
Non mais tu as peur de quoi ? Enfin,
genre si si à un moment pourquoi pas un
flingue et quelques cartouches si tu as
peur de quelque chose, mais là h
flingues c'est peut-être enfin et et il
était là, bah je sais pas mais au cas où
je suis prêt. Et ça m'a marqué comme
comme réponse en fait. Il savait il
était concret, il était sincère, ilit je
sais pas mais au cas où si quelqu'un
rentre chez moi, je suis prêt. Mais il
savait pas qui pourrait rentrer chez lui
ou pourquoi on pourrait rentrer chez lui
ou pourquoi on lui en voudrait ou machin
mais il était déjà prêt avec ses
flingues et ses hiss
c'est quoi ? C'était un stress
post-traumatique d'un seul parmi la
centaine de parce que je pense qu' comme
il discutait sincèrement avec nous, ça
avait l'air d'être enfin son truc quoi.
Mais il en avait pas honte, au
contraire, il l'assumait mais c'était un
moment vraiment sociologiquement méga
intéressant de pouvoir se retrouver à
l'hôtel avec une compagnie de CRS qui
qui travaillait pas à Calé en plus à ce
moment-là de
Est-ce que est-ce qu' ils t'ont fait
part des des séquels de voir cette
misère ? Est-ce qu'ils t'ont fait part
de de Ils
sont foutaient complètement ça ? Par
contre, quand on a parlé des migrants,
ouais, ça, on a pas envie d'en parler.
De toute façon, nous
c'est un mécanisme de défense comme un
autre
peut-être, mais façon, enfin,
franchement, concrètement, n'importe
quelle personne normalement constitué.
Après, il y a les gens d'extrême droite,
mais qui va dans
c'est gratuit ça,
non ? Mais bon, qui va dans un camp de
réfugié en France parce que on est les
pires d'Europe. Euh, on vaut pas mieux
que la Hongrie, je tiens à le dire et
j'y étais pour le voir quoi. Euh, qui va
dans un camp de réfugié, quelqu'un de
normalement constitué, il ressort pas
indem ou alors il a un problème. Enfin,
donc j'en parle, j'en j'ai pas fini,
mais il y avait un membre de mon équipe,
il a mis un an et demi à se remettre
d'un reportage de 3 jours à calé, quoi.
Euh, il pouvait pas dormir. Enfin, un
vrai syndrome de stress
post-traumatique, quoi. Et je le salue.
Bon courage à toi si ça revient encore,
quoi. Et je comprends pourquoi euh je
pourrais même pas te raconter ce qu'on a
vu pour qu'il a un tress pasatif parce
que ta vidéo elle serait flashée sur
YouTube.
C'est ça euh qu' est ça continue, c'est
tous les jours. Enfin, il y a quelque
chose qui quand quand j'étais petit, il
y avait 100 gat.
Quand tu quand tu filmes tout ça, les
interventions CRS, quand il déchirent
les tentes, quand ils arrachent les gars
et ainsi de suite, toi ça te fait quoi ?
Toi, tu es derrière ton objectif, tu
mets de la distance. J'ai pas été j'ai
été interdit de par contre le judiciaire
d'aller à Calé pendant un an et demi.
Donc j'ai pas été
quoi ? C'est à cause de l'histoire de
Toky Wolky là
quoi tu as été
que j'aurais volé machin truc et que tu
connais Non, tuas tu as pas fait Ah, tu
as pas bien travaillé. Si si, je sais,
je sais même que tu as pris 300 € pour
un doigt d'honneur. Magnifique.
Oui, ça c'était le doigt d'honneur mais
le Toky Walky c'était encore autre
chose. Le Toky Wolky d'ailleurs je tiens
à saluer mes avocats Raphaël Kemf et Aoa
Pasqual euh sans qui je serai
probablement en prison plutôt que en
train de faire une interview pour une
raison à la con qu'ils auraient trouvé
pour me faire chier. Mais le Toky Wolky
c'était une sacrée histoire quand même.
Euh on est au moment d'une
semi-évacuation de la jungle de Calé.
Euh la police recule face à une charge
de migrants qui ont 14 ans qui leur
balancent des petits cailloux sur eux.
Enfin voilà. Et dans la panique, il y a
il y a un flic qui perd un tookywolie
qui se trouve être un toky walkie de
enfin c'était la dernière dernière
innovation. C'était un tetrapoffré
chiffré écran couleur euh c'est l'iPhone
des Toky Wid de machin. Et on s'en est
pas du tout rendu compte tout de suite.
Il tombait dans un espèce de buisson.
C'est juste que il pleuvait, c'était un
temps de merde. Ça fait 6h qu'on se
faisait gazer. Genre on en avait autre
chose à [__] que s'occuper de ça,
quoi. Et en fait, c'est juste que comme
le le volume était à fond, on entendait
un buisson qui parlait au milieu du
bordel. Ça faisait 6 he qu'on se faisait
gazer sous la pluie. Tout on a un
buisson qui donne des ordres. C'est quoi
? Il se passe quoi ? Et en fait, on est
allé voir et c'est là qu'on voit le
Toki. Et en fait, pour le prendre en
photo, je l'ai pris en main. Grave
erreur. Voilà, j'ai été accusé d'avoir
volé le toki. Voilà. Euh le Toki, il a
fini dans les mains des réfugiés qui
sont amusés à gueuler à la wakar dedans
pour faire chier les flics et c'était
extrêmement drôle et parce qu'ils
étaient voilà, c'était pas c'était pas
du tout religieux, c'était juste pour
les faire chier et voilà et euh je l'ai
vu être balancé dans le dans le le lac
de la jungle et mais du coup donc quand
je suis retourné à Calé pour
l'évacuation un mois après euh dès
qu'ils m'ont vu, ils m'ont arrêté. Euh
j'ai fait 48 heures de garde à vue à
Calé. Euh génial le commissaire de
Caléin. Franchement, j'ai visité des
châteaux forts, ils sont plus modernes.
Et euh
ensuite, j'ai été interdit par contrôle
judiciaire d'aller à Cal pendant 1 an et
demi. J'ai eu mon procès 1 an après et
j'ai eu 500 € d'amende pour vol de Toky
Wolky de la police. Voilà. Mais
franchement, avec tout ce que j'ai pris,
j'aurais préféré le garder.
Bref,
revenons revenons sur le la violence
dans les deux camp.
La violence de
dans les deux camps. H
en manif, euh comment toi en tant que
journaliste, tu perçois la violence des
manifestants ?
Est-ce que tu peux préciser ta question
? Quand tu vois, alors je je vais la
faire d'une façon détournée. Quand tu
entends les flics dire "Oh là, on a pris
des cocktails chimiques sur la gueule à
la sous caustique, on a pris des pavés,
il y en a un qui a pris euh 25 jours
dit, il y en a un qui est handicapé et
ainsi de suite." Tu comprends, tu
comprends pas ? Tu en discutes avec eux,
tu en discutes pas. Toi, quand tu vois
des manifestants en face, tu gardes tes
distances, tu dis rien. Tu les vois, tu
dis tiens ça change. Et ils prennent
d'autres dispositions. Bah
mon rôle fondamentalement en tant que
journaliste, c'est de ne pas prendre
partie. Donc un moment
logiquement je vois un flic se prend
molotof avec la même peine que je vois
un manifestant se prendre un flash ball
dans la gueule. Enfin il y a pas de
différence en fait. Euh je suis allé
couvrir la banif pro Palestine samedi.
Ça s'est passé
euh bah c'était une overdose policière.
Il y avait 1 km 4 de police dans ce
sens-là, 1 km 4 dans l'autre. pour je
sais même pas comment ils ont réussi à
manifester. Euh mais euh mais en gros
voilà, enfin euh ta religion, tes choix
sexuels, ta vie privée, c'est pas mon
problème et je m'en fous. Enfin, si
demain on m'apporte la photo de
Jean-Marie Le Pen ou sa fille en train
de en pleine partous où on peut les
identifier ou voilà, je le publierai
jamais. Ils font ce qu'ils veulent,
c'est leur problème. C'est c'est pas à
moi de faire ça. Je suis pas paris
match, je suis pas je suis pas h je suis
pas voilà, je mon boulot c'est de filmer
ce qui se passe. Si un moment les gens
ils font les cons dans les deux camps,
c'est à eux de l'assumer. Après
évidemment ça ça a été un grand débat
mais c'est pas mon boulot de mettre des
manifestants en prison. C'est pas mon
boulot de faire le travail de la police.
Euh il y a
Pourquoi tu dis ça ?
Hein ?
Pourquoi tu dis ça ? parce que ça a été
un grand débat euh avant qu'apparaisse
les lives d'ailleurs enfin que se
multiplient les lives sur les les gens
qui faisaient des vidéos en manif parce
que ben il y a pas mal de de d'enquêtes
judiciaires où les la police s'est
servie euh dans les images de de
journalistes. Aujourd'hui le débat c'est
un peu calmé parce que clairement les
gens qui font des images en live bah ils
ont aucun contrôle dessus. Ils sont tout
de suite captés par les serveurs de la
police. Donc c'est beaucoup plus eux qui
servent de de truc. Je suis assez fier
que mes images n'ont jamais été citées
dans un dossier judiciaire pour accuser
qui que ce soit et cetera parce que je
m'en serais vraiment voulu. Mais euh ça
nécessite un certain travail. Ça veut
dire qu'à un moment quand tu rentres le
soir et que tu fais le montage toute la
nuit, une partie du travail parmi
lesquels enlever les doublons,
raccourcir les plan et cetera, s'il y a
un mec qui a assz enfin qui qui balance
un truc sur les flics à visage
découvert, il est face à eux, il prend
le risque face à eux, c'est son problème
mais qu'il se retourne et qu'on voit son
visage, bah mon travail c'est de couper
avant qu'il se retourne pour qu'on voit
pas son visage ou alors de pas mettre ce
plan. Mais si
quand c'est un flic, est-ce que tu fais
pareil
hein ? Quand c'est un flic par exemple,
on a vu la sur les Champs-Élysées, il y
en a un qui s'est amusé à balancer un
bout dein
un flic c'est différent. Pourquoi ?
Un flic c'est un représentant de l'État,
un
policier,
il est payé euh par nous. Euh il il a il
a un code, il a désordre un manifestant
et il agit selon ses envies, quoi. Mais
un policier c'est comme un militaire
normalement. Enfin
attention.
Oui mais enfin tu vois ce que je veux
dire, il a il doit il doit respecter des
ordres. Donc à un moment, s'il déconne
dans le respect de ses ordres, c'est
aussi important qu'un manifestant qui
dépasse, si tu veux les limites normales
de ce qu'on peut considérer comme une
manife, quoi. Euh voilà. Mais encore une
fois, non, tous les événements sont
traités de la même manière. tu peux pas
faire tu si un moment je par exemple je
vais en manifestation proalestine et et
que d'une manière ou d'une autre je
montre de de
la proximité avec le mouvement pro
palestinien bah je pourrais plus couvrir
des manifestants des manifestations pro
Israël ça va pas ce serait la même chose
avec la Chine et Taiïwan ce serait la
même chose avec le Mexique et les
États-Unis c'est vraiment tu ne peux pas
prendre partie sinon tu te coupes en
deux en fait tu ne fais plus qu'une
partie tu ne fais plus qu'une qu'un
morceau de ton travail en fait tu n'as
plus accès Et je pense tu as pas la même
vision non plus de la situation si tu ne
couvres qu'un seul camp quoi en fait.
Tu m'autorises à ouvrir une parenthèse.
Bah oui.
Est-ce que tu trouves que les
journalistes en France
ont une déontologie, une conscience
professionnelle irréprochable ?
Oh, c'est dégueulasse. Euh,
ça dépend lesquel. Euh à cette place et
j'en suis très honoré était assise Elise
Lu euh
on passe le bonjour d'ailleurs.
Ouais, je Elise et vous l'avez pas lavé
depuis j'espère.
Mais
tu sais qu'on lui a donné un petit
surnom.
Ah merde, il y a le Covid. Mais euh Non,
mais oui, non, j'ai énormément de
respect pour pour Élise Lu en France. Il
y a quand même encore des journalistes
qui sauvent l'honneur. Euh
malheureusement, on on vient d'apprendre
que TF1 a racheté M6 en plus. Donc euh
ça va devenir encore plus compliqué.
Mais là le entre avec l'élection
présidentielle qui arrive entre C8, BFM,
la course à l'audience, à la pub qui a
diminué à cause du Covid machin, on
atteint un niveau
euh je suis fatigué quand là en plus à
Paris, je suis à l'hôtel. Du coup, ça
m'arrive de manger en regardant BFM et
je suis là mais mais où est-ce qu'on est
arrivé quoi ? Est-ce que la presse
participe à la radicalisation des gens,
au clivage des gens ?
Je pense que là la presse, elle
participe à la stupidisation collective,
quoi. Enfin, c'est c'est fatiguant,
quoi. Qu'est-ce qu'il a dit l'autre là,
Philippe Devilier là, qu'il avait guéri
du Covid en buvant du pastisme prescrit
par Didier Raout ? Non mais c'est du
Trump quoi.
On mérite mieux que ça là. Franchement,
on est fatigué après le Covid là, un
moment le débat politique, on est un an
des élections présentes, il devrait
s'élever un peu là. Euh comment ?
Bah c'est pas à moi de le dire encore
une fois, mais comment ? En arrêtant
d'être stupide déjà quoi de de faire des
déjà en arrêtant de parler de de sujets
qui n'en sont pas quoi. Le voile en
France, on s'en fout. Mais [__] mais
on s'en fout.
Çaessort tout le temps. Méchant il faut
même pas franchement. Moi à l'université
R2, j'avais une prof qui avait le voile
mais
en université
à l'université elle était prof. Mais il
y a jamais personne qui l'a fait chier.
Il y a jamais personne qui a trouvé ça
anormal. Il y a jamais personne qui a
enfin
donc à un moment ressortir ça et le
mettre hein, c'est vraiment une preuve
qu'on rentre de nouveau dans dans cette
volonté de d'orienter le débat politique
à l'extrême droite, tu vois. Euh euh
alors ils ont essayé avec les violences
policières, ils ont essayé avec la
presse. Maintenant c'est c'est euh c'est
le voile machin tout ça me fatigue quoi.
Le voile, on entend parler depuis que je
suis au collège quoi. Euh c'était c'est
le le débat du voile c'était Chirak
encore. Euh
il y a des il y a des techniciens ou des
des des politiques qui parlaient du
voile dans les années 2000 qui sont
morts aujourd'hui. Faudrait peut-être
qu'on passe à autre chose. Enfin que que
le débat soit un petit peu orienté. En
je sais pas. Voilà.
Esquiviver un peu la presse la presse
papier ou la presse télévisuelle. Est-ce
que tu sens que il y a une idéologie
dans la plupart du temps ? Est-ce que il
il respecte la charte de Munique ?
D'ailleurs, quelle question ?
C'est quoi la charte de Munique ?
Alors, la charte Dominique c'est tu as
vraiment des questions
mais la Charte de Munique c'est pas
compliqué, on est censé tous la
respecter en fait. Sauf qu'aujourd'hui
euh ben à peu près comme moi, personne
l'a lu quoi. Donc euh
tu sais toi ce que tu tu pourrais me la
décrire là les les droits et devoirs du
journalisme.
Oui, c'est ça. Je sais ce que c'est mais
euh mais après en détail, bon c'est très
long déjà, c'est très gros.
En gros, je te la résume en simple,
d'accord ? C'est c'est la partie que que
j'adore résumer d'une façon très
triviale. On ne fait passeur de soupe,
on ne passe pas les plats.
Oui. Ben oui,
je je te dis quand je regarde C8 ou BFM,
j'arrive plus. J'ai il y a il y a des
émissions où ça va, ça reste encore de
l'information à peu près, mais euh le
délire de Twitch, tu vois, d'inviter des
gens euh à faire genre euh machin,
Twitch à la base c'est un truc de gamer,
quoi. C'est un truc de gosse qui joue à
Starcraft 2, quoi. Euh
ah bah on n pas obligé d'être gosse pour
jouer à Starcraft 2.
Non, en plus je joue à Starcraft 2
aussi, ça m'arrive. Voilà.
Mais mais voilà, enfin je à la base,
c'est quoi ta race sur Starcraft 2 ?
est plus chiant quoi.
Mais j'ai joué à Starcraft 1 encore il y
a longtemps. Euh mais non, enfin voilà,
essayer de enfin arriver à se dire de
manière aussi grossière que on va
pouvoir communiquer auprès des jeunes en
venant sur un service de streaming pour
jeux vidéo.
Les mecs, ils ont fait des études
supérieures quoi. OK. C'est
mais ça c'est parce que tu les connais
pas assez c'est pour ça.
Enfin je pas fait d'études en
communication mais j'ai l'impression
qu'on en a pas beaucoup besoin quoi.
C'est pas étude en communication, on dit
sculpteur de fumée, brasseur d'air
chaud. Enfin moi j'aimerais bien voir
Olivier Verrand jouer à Starcraft plutôt
que de commenter son salaire en fait.
Quitte à le faire venir sur Twitch quoi.
Autant que ça soit drôle quoi. Euh parce
que à un moment ce serait enfin ça doit
pas être sur Twitch que le ministre de
la santé révèle le montant de son
salaire.
à quel moment devenus normal. En fait,
c'est une question qui aurait dû être
posée par un journaliste sur un plateau
télé, pas sur un truc de game.
On a oublié en fait, on est la
grenouille dans le bol d'eau chaude
quoi. Et et là, ça commence à bouillir
quoi. Et on est et on est là genre ouais
c'est bon, il fait doux, tout va bien,
machin mais on est en train de cuill.
Si ça continue comme ça au mois de
septembre, Zemour il présente le journal
de France 2 quoi.
Ah non, c'est vrai, il va être candidat,
pardon.
Non. Aucune idée.
On verra.
Donc revenons, revenons à la déontologie
journalistique. Quel est pour toi le
pire scandale que tu pu voir en terme de
déontologie journalistique ? W
Oh, très dure question.
Euh,
c'est pas le pire, mais c'est c'est le
premier qui m'est venu à l'esprit.
C'est celui que je vais te présenter
mais ça peut pas être le pire et cetera.
Mais Casneu qui était au journal de
France 2, on est en 2016 pendant le loi
de travail l'histoire de l'hôpital Neer,
les vitres de l'hôpital Neer. J'étais
juste à côté en fait quand c'est quand
c'est arrivé. Donc il y a un manifestant
qui a pété les vitres et
un manifestant ou un black block ?
C'est un manifestant.
Voilà, a priori d'après ce d'après
l'enquête qui avait été faite à
l'interne des manifestants, c'était même
pas un manifestant français, c'éit un
manifestant allemand qui était en France
et du coup non seulement bah déjà même
il aurait pas été parisien, il aurait
pas su que c'étapital Neer. Enfin, c'est
pas les vitres quand tu es en bat, c'est
pas c'est pas marqué
une assurance de banque. C'est
voilà, il a dû se dire c'est une banque.
Voilà. Et du coup, il a pété des trucs
et le soir 15 à 20h pile, la manif elle
avait dû finir à 19h30 donc il avait
bien préparé son truc quoi. Ouais, c'est
un scandale. Ils ont attaqué l'hôpital
Necker. Ça donnait l'impression qu'on
est enfin que les manifestants étaient
rentrés dans l'hôpital pour attaquer les
enfants quoi, tu vois. et leur manger le
les les membres quoi. Alors que bon,
c'était une vitre qui avait été pétée
parmi les 50000 vitres qui avaient brûlé
dans cette manife quoi. C'était une très
grosse manif. Je crois que c'était
Ouais, c'était le 14 juin. C'était une
des pires manifes de tout le mouvement
social. Donc à un moment se concentrer
juste sur ça, j'avais trouvé la
manipulation vraiment grossière et ça
avait été repris pendant 24h, 48h et
personne n'avait vraiment fait le
travail de bon où sont les images,
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé, quels sont
les vrais dégâts et cetera. Alors que
concrètement sur le terrain, on était 50
à avoir filmé le truc quoi. Il y avait
au moins au moins 15 pigistes qui
avaient proposé leurs images à tous les
médias de France de exactement ce
moment-là et elles n'ont pas été acheté
quoi. Il préférait utiliser Casneu qui
disait que c'était un scandale et
cetera. Mais la vérité, elle est restée
un peu voilà, c'est pas du tout le pire
scandale, il y en a eu plein. Mais mais
c'est espèce de manipulation politique.
Si en a eu plein, donne-mois-en deux
autres.
Pardon ?
S'il y en a eu plein, donne-mois-en deux
autres.
Non, c'est trop dur comme question.
Fais-en une autre. Non non non non,
c'est trop dur. C'est trop dur. Euh
j'essaie de penser récemment pour que ça
puisse être en rapport avec Macron.
Vas-y, je te sauve si tu veux. Mais en
fait là le le plateau de de C8 quand
c'est des débats avec des intervenants
qui vont jamais sur le terrain qui sont
experts de rien du tout en fait qui ont
écrit un bouquin qui a été vendu à 10000
exemplaires auprès d'une population qui
de toute façon acheter déjà les mêmes
livres. Quand ces gens-là se réunissent
sur un plateau télé et font quelque
chose qu'ils appellent de l'information,
pour moi çaen est pas.
C'est quoi ? C'est-à-dire que un moment
quand tu tu prends des é meour il est
écrivant, on pourrait dire qu'il a une
une semi-ilégitimité encore que Mais euh
quand tu prends ces gens-là et que tu
leur fais parler de l'actualité, c'est
pas de l'information, c'est du débat,
c'est de la politique mais c'est pas de
l'information.
C'est quoi l'information ?
L'information c'est factuelle. Qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé ? Qu'est-ce que les gens
ont dit ? Comment ils l'ont vécu ? Point
bar. sans déformer comme qu'est-ce que X
pense de cette situation ? Je m'en fous.
Alors tous ceux qui s'y intéressent, ils
peuvent mais ça c'est pas de
l'information, c'est
de la politique, c'est du débat, c'est
de l'échange entre personnes, voilà.
Mais c'est pas de l'information.
L'information c'est l'effet,
l'image, le son, les gens, point.
L'analyse c'est autre chose. C'est un
autre domaine, c'est d'autres gens. Donc
essayez de faire passer du débat
politique pour de l'information. C'est
le piège qui est en train de se produire
pour la présidentière l'avocat du
diable. Cazz9, il a peut-être vu euh euh
un black block allemand tabasser euh les
vitres de l'hôpital Nequer et lui c'est
sa vérité.
Ah non non, c'est c'est la stratégie
politique qu'il a mis en place sur le
plateau télé de France I pour pouvoir
faire un contre-coup social à un
événement qui prenait de l'ampleur
parce que c'est choquant de qu'un
hôpital soit attaqué et du coup ça
décrédibilisait le mouvement tout
simplement. C'était politique. Enfin
c'est une stratégie très grossière. elle
a fonctionné par ailleurs.
Comment toi, reporteur de journaliste
d'image ou journaliste de terrain,
tu analyses la crise des gilets jaunes ?
Il faut que tu répètes action.
Comment toi en tant en tant que
professionnel tu analyses la crise des
gilets jaunes et sa couverture
médiatique ?
Alors ça paraît paradoxal parce que j'ai
quand même fumé pas mal de man dans ma
vie mais moi je l'ai pas vu venir la
crise des gilets jaunes. Pas du tout.
Euh il y a plein de gens qui qui disent
"Oui, moi la crise des gilets jaunes, ça
fait 10 ans que". Non, personne n'a vu
venir. C'est absolument c'était
imprévisible. Mais en même temps, quand
ça a commencé, euh
on a compris que ça allait prendre une
ampleur considérable parce que la
largeur de ce que ça a grippé
socialement euh c'est rarement arrivé
euh dans la 5e République, un mouvement
social euh vise aussi large. Euh quand à
un moment il y avait des les premières
manifestes sur les Champs éélysées
politiquement il y avait tout le monde,
l'extrême droite, l'extrême gauche, le
les bailleristes, les viliétistes, les
macronistes qui étaient pas contents,
les tout ce que tu veux. Enfin, il y
avait tout le spectre politique dans la
manif. Ça n'arrive jamais à part pour
peut-être un hommage après des attentats
ou un truc comme ça, tu vois. Mais mais
politiquement, en général, une manife
revendicative, c'est la droite ou la
gauche. Mais ils sont rarement ensemble.
C'est vraiment et donc à un moment
c'était même assez bizarre parce qu'il y
avait des il y avait des manifestants
connus et ouvertement d'extrême droite
en tête de cortège complètement déchaîné
parce qu'ils ont pas trop l'habitude de
faire ce manif et tu avais des mecs
d'extrême gauche en bloc qui étaient
derrière qui étaient là genre [__]
mais attends mais ces garsl mais c'est
pas c'est pas nos camarades quoi. Et
c'était super bizarre parce que
justement il y avait tellement de monde
qui arrivent en même temps que il y
avait des ambigués politiques des pas
nos camarades alors que c'était à peu
près les mêmes luttes. C'était bizarre
politiquement le les G jaunes parce que
ça a un peu commencé brouillon. Ça a
viré rapidement d'extrême droite un peu
complotiste machin. C'est reparti à
gauche avant Noël et début janvier,
février. Puis quand ça
Comment tu as senti ça ?
Pardon ?
Comment je l'ai senti ? C'est-à-dire
bah pour dire que c'était un peu machin
puis ça b tu vois dans tu le vois dans
la méthodologie, tu le vois dans le
public qui va au manif.
Euh à ce moment-là, j'ai j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir rentrer à Strasbourg
pour faire des des images sur sur les
mouvang zone en province. Et c'est plus
facile en province qu'à Paris parce que
Paris, il y a des gens qui viennent
manifester à Paris deux provinces. Donc
c'est un peu mélangé avec le public
local. Puis Paris, ça représente pas
vraiment la démographie française. Quand
tu es en province, dans une grande ville
de province, ça tu sais que ça ce qui se
passe là, ça peut se reproduire ailleurs
dans une autre ville de province. Ça a
plus de probabilité de se produire. Et
euh et donc oui, à Strasbourg, j'ai
rapidement pu reconnaître un peu plus
facilement euh euh qui était de droite,
qui était de gauche et cetera. Mais
comment fait pour reconnaître les gens
de droite et de gauche ? C'est la coupe
de cheveux, c'est les chaussures, c'est
quoi ? dans les champs dans les champs
revendicatifs dans un moment dans les
manifs à Paris en question, il y a des
mecs il faisaient des salut éclairériens
encore au début du moment des gilets
jaunes. Ils se sont fait frapper tout de
suite, ça a été radical mais il y a eu
des salués éclairiens sur les champs
élysées les premières manifes. Ah ils
sont fait sortir immédiatement, ça a pas
duré longtemps. Mais en plus on é à côté
de la place de la Concorde, ils auraient
dû faire gaffe.
C'était une minorité, c'était trois
connards et tondus. C'était quoi ? C'est
je te dis il y a le moment des gilets
jaunes, il y avait une colère
collectivement ressentie mais vraiment
pas vu venir par qui que ce soit, même
pas par les sociologues qui est sorti
d'un coup. Du coup, tout le monde est
sorti dans la rue en même temps et s'est
retrouvé un peu mélangé quoi. Et il y a
c'est socialement c'est vraiment je
pense qu'on mettra des années à
comprendre le mouvement des gilets
jaunes. C'est parti sur le prix de
l'essence. Qu'est-ce qu'il y a de plus
rassembleur que le prix du pétrole dans
la voiture, quoi. À partir de là,
effectivement, que ce soit des gens de
la classe moyenne, des gens de de des
gens pauvres, ça concerne vraiment
beaucoup de monde, le prix de l'essence,
donc et de tous les bords politiques.
Euh donc voilà, c'est c'était un moment
qui était très intéressant
politiquement. Après, la manière dont il
s'est terminé, parce qu'on peut dire
qu'il est terminé, même s'il y en a qui
pensent que c'est pas le cas, mais bon,
c'est ça a du mal un peu à s'arrêter.
Après, le monde de gilets jaune a permis
l'émergence de beaucoup de choses très
intéressantes, notamment en terme
d'information puisque il y en a plein
maintenant qui font des lives avec leur
téléphone. Je suis pas très pro live
déjà parce que c'est relativement moche.
Ensuite parce que enfin c'est c'est dur
à regarder une deuxième fois quand ça
dure 5 he et cetera. Et euh et puis bah
oui, quand tu es en manif ça peut mettre
des gens en danger parce que tu as aucun
contrôle sur tes images en fait. Si un
moment tu te rends compte que tu viens
de filmer le visage d'un mec qui a
balancé un cocktail molotof sur un flic
qui va rester 15 ans de prison, que tu
aurais pu avoir cette image sans
forcément cramer la gueule du mec, bah
là c'est trop tard si tu es en direct,
si tu es avec des disques dur cryptés en
train de faire ton montage machin,
bah tu sais que potentiellement le mec
tu l'envoies pas en prison quoi. C'est
quand même une bonne différence quoi.
Tu chiffres tes cartes mémoire, tu
chiffres tes
al pas te décrle mais il est très
sérieux. Euh
chiffre avec quoi ? Je vais pas te
décrire mon protocole mais il est très
sérieux. Je paye des nourrices pour
cacher mes disques durs comme si j'étais
un dealer. C'est-à-dire que il y a des
gens que je connais mais qui sont pas
dans mes cercles extrêmement proches
pour pas qu'on puisse les machin mais
que je rémunère pour cacher mes disques
dur cryptés avec mes archives.
Chiffrés.
Chiffré. Oui, pardon. Et euh mais on en
est là quoi. Et euh
pourquoi tu fais ça ?
Pourquoi je fais ça ? Euh parce que j'ai
pas envie d'avoir une perquise le matin
et je sais qu'ils le savent et que c'est
probablement pour ça que j'en ai jamais
eu. C'est-à-dire que ils peuvent venir
là, je dois avoir les images.
Tu serais perquisitionné
en perquisition. Tu
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi il viendrait chez
toi à 6h du matin ?
Ah bah j'ai j'ai eu un milliard de garde
à vue pour rien. J'ai été explosé pour
rien. Je dire je peux m'attendre à tout.
Enfin donc je j'ai pas envie d'avoir une
perquisition. Mais
est-ce que tu as déjà été approché par
les services de renseignant pour faire
la balance ?
Jamais. Euh je pense qu'ils ont compris
que c'était pas la peine. C'est en
analysant mon attitude et mes
fréquentations, peut-être qu'ils ont
compris que c'était pas la peine
d'essayer. Mais je connais des gens à
qui c'est arrivé dans le milieu du
journalisme. Euh ils ont essayé pas mal
sur les jeunes photographes euh qui
commençaient et c'est vraiment bâtard
parce qu'ils les ont ils les ont tagué
quand ils étaient encore en étude. Ça
veut dire ils étaient encore en train de
ils étaient encore étudiants
en train d'apprendre à faire de la
photo. En même temps, ils étaient déjà
en manif pour travailler mais ils
étaient encore étudiants et c'est là
qu'ils sont allés les voir. Ils sont au
début de carrière, tu vois, ils ont pas
encore de contact machin, les mecs le on
va te filer de la tune, un appareil
machin et tout. Et alors heureusement,
il y en a un d'ailleurs Maxime Reier qui
l'a raconté sur Twitter récemment
et qui fait un travail sur le maintien
de l'ordre aussi. Et d'ailleurs, j'ai
même pas cité mes mes deux collègues,
mais je vais le faire immédiatement. Je
tiens à dire bonjour à Ulis Logéat et
Anna Nelson euh qui sont les deux
photographes de Taranis et qui
travaillent extrêmement bien et qui sont
qui sont jeunes aussi et qui font un
travail que au même âge on aurait jamais
fait. C'est-à-dire que ça aussi c'est
quelque chose que je voulais préciser.
Comment est-ce que tout a changé au
niveau manifestant et policiers ? Ça a
extrêmement changé au niveau journaliste
aussi. Euh moi il y a 10 ans, je filmais
pas avec des protections. J'avais pas de
casque, j'avais pas de masque à gaz,
j'avais une écharpe sur le j'avais une j
là-bas que ma mère m'avait ramené du
Maroc en plus que je portais autour que
les flics m'ont piqué d'ailleurs, que je
portais euh pour me protéger de la
lacrima, c'est tout. Euh en 10 ans, on
est devenu des Robocop. Euh on a des on
a des des chaussures renforcées, on a
des protections de footballeur là, des
machins pour se jeter par terre ici, des
trucs de OK sur les bras, un casque de
que même Michael Schumerer, il serait
pas mort. Euh
ah non, merde, il est pas mort. Euh
pardon. Euh on a le masque on a les
masques à gaz avec des filtres qui
filtreraient des machins de plombs que
tu peux mettre ta tête dans la peinture.
Euh
et et tout ça, ça s'est accumulé avec
les années. Et ça s'est pas accumulé
parce que on est allé chez Deécathlon en
voulant faire les malins et cetera. Non,
parce qu'on a été blessé en fait. Euh le
nombre de grenades, de coups de machin.
Je sais pas s'il y a une un seul membre
de l'équipe de Taranis, de toute
l'histoire de Taranist. Je sais plus
combien il y a 12 ou 13 personnes qui
sont passées en tout qui a jamais été
blessé. On a tous forcément eu au moins
un palais de la crémau, un palais de
désencerclant ou un flashball.
Airton Sena, si tu veux parler de
casque.
Aon Sena, si tu veux parler de casque.
Oui, mais bon, j'étais petit quand même.
Mais
revenons à l'approche des services de
renseignement sur les journalistes et
les photographes dès le berceau. Ça se
passe comment ? Bah ça m'est pas arrivé
donc je peux pas te
Est-ce que tu en as entendu plus de
décrire
d'après ce que Maxime a décrit euh sur
Twitter donc les gens peuvent aller
regarder c'est euh et ben ils ont pris
rendez-vous avec lui, ils l'ont appelé.
De toute façon, les les flics quand ils
ont besoin, ils ont toujours ton numéro
de téléphone. Ça, il y a pas de
problème. Quand tu vois un numéro privé,
en général, au début, je répondais pas
au numéro privé, maintenant je réponds
parce que je sais que c'est les flics.
Et quand j'étais en contrôle judiciaire,
c'était ça. Genre euh en fait, j'ai j'ai
fait un truc avec eux parce qu'ils sont
venus une fois là où j'habitais à à 7h
du mat et pour une convo de merde, enfin
pour te faire signer un papier quoi. Le
truc que on peut te dire vous passez au
commissariat signé un papier dans la
journée, ça va quoi. Tu vois, ils sont
mis à 7h du matin, trois flics, la sale
gueule machin. Moi j'étais en caleçon
dehors. Qu'est-ce que vous voulez quoi ?
Genre [__] une perquise non je faire
signer un papier quoi. Et je dis mais
pourquoi vous venez à pourquoi papier
machin ? Bah tiens voilà c'est bon
casse-toi truc machin. Bah il est parti
voilà du coup j'ai appelé
parlait comme ça
hein.
Pourquoi il parlait comme ça ? parce que
c'est le matin, tu es de mauvaise
humeur, le matin.
Bah oui. Enfin, genre tu réveilles
quelqu'un à 7h du matin juste pour lui
faire signer un papier, alors tu pouvais
le faire venir dans la journée, c'est
juste pour le faire chier. Donc il va
pas enfin je vais pas être de bonne
humeur pour leur faire plaisir quoi. Et
du coup je le comme je devais signer
tous les toutes les semaines au
commissariat pour le contrôle judiciaire
à la signature d'après, il y avait le
commandant qui était excusez-moi
monsieur le commandant, j'aimerais juste
vous voir et tout et j'ai j'ai un numéro
de téléphone. Si vous avez un papier à
faire signer, vous pouvez m'appeler et
je prends mon vélo en une demi-heure,
une heure, je suis là quoi. Il y a pas
de problème. il y a pas besoin de venir
chez moi. Et parce que là sinon, j'étais
très énervé en fait et je lui dis sinon
je peux aussi rester à Strasbourg vous
faire un reportage sur tout ce qui se
passe au port du rein, les prostituées,
la la place de la gare et cetera me
mettre à la sortie du commissariat
suivre toutes vos patrouilles de flic
pour voir ce qui se passe en banlieu à
Strasbourg et j'en aurai des choses à
montrer quoi. Et là non, moi je suis
très content que vous soyez à Paris
vraiment mais il y a pas de problème
maintenant quand j'ai besoin de vous je
vous appelle et je vous jure il y aura
plus jamais un policier qui vient à 7h
du matin et ça n'est plus jamais arrivé.
Voilà donc j'ai un espèce de semi-accord
avec la police de Strasbourg ils ne
viennent pas ils m'appellent je viens et
en échange je je m'installe pas à
Strasbourg voilà c'est deal sinon je
leur fais la totale.
C'est une façon d'acheter ton silence
sur ta région ?
Euh il y a ma famille à Strasbourg. J'ai
envie d'avoir la paix, tu vois, genre
parce que à un moment j'arrive, enfin
non mais j'arrive à supporter la
pression policière et il faudrait plus
que 3 heur pour décrire tout ce que ça
représente. Moment, tu as tes proches,
tu as 3 heur, vas-y.
Tuas tu as une copine, tu as des potes,
tu as une famille et la pression
policière que tu subis déjà eux ils ont
du mal mais des fois ils la subissent
aussi directement.
De quel genre ? la camionnette de la
DGSI en bas de la porte à Paris tout le
temps. Euh en plus ils sont vraiment pas
discrets quoi. Non mais vraiment c'est
c'est mais Didier mais faites un effort
quoi. Franchement mais apprenez être
discret ou alors ou alors ils s'en
foutent hein. Mais euh mais voilà Didier
c'est Ouais Didier c'est c'est une
manière c'est une manière de non pas
Didier l'allemand mais c'est une manière
d'appeler la police quoi. Gérald Didier,
c'est pas de ma faute si le préfet
s'appelle Didier et le ministre
s'appelle Gérald. Mais mais en gros oui,
la camionnette de la DGSI, les
filatures, il y en a un jour je l'ai je
l'ai poursuivi pendant 1 heure et demi
parce que il me je sortais pour aller
faire les courses et je vois que je suis
suivi et ce jour là, j'étais vraiment
pas de bonne humeur et je me retrouve,
je fais quoi maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il
y a ? [__] je vais faire les courses
quoi. Et il fait genre il dit rien, il
regarde le CEL et cetera. Je fais bon,
tu m'énerves. J'ai sorti mon téléphone,
j'allume la la vidéo et je lui mets en
pleine gueule et je fais maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'il y a ? Et on a il a
commencé, il avait son oreillette,
c'était vraiment pas discret. Il une
grosse oreillette noire d'un seul côté,
donc c'était pas une oreillette pour
écouter de la musique.
Il te dit que c'était la DGSI ?
Non mais enfin il répondait pas, il
fuyait mon regard, il essayait de se
tourner pour pas que je vois bref et il
a commencé à marcher de plus en plus
vite machin et moi je le suivais
derrière, je me suis dit je vais te
suivre jusqu'au commissariat quoi. Et on
a marché comme ça pendant ouais 1 heure
1 km jusqu'à ce que j'abandonne. J'en a
marre. Mais c'est tout le temps, tout le
temps, tout le temps, tout le temps.
C'est
quand quand mes potes me croient pas euh
maintenant ils ont capté le truc mais
quand mes potes me croient pas et ça
arrive que tu es parano et tout. À
Paris, oui, à Strasbourg, ça va mais je
je les emmène dans le métro.
Euh là quand je viens ici ça va mais à
une à un moment où il y a une
potentielle surveillance avant une
manifestation, après une manifestation
parce que je vais quelque part qui ait
potentiellement politique et cetera.
Bref, on va dans le métro, on sort à
n'importe quelle station.
Est-ce qu'un journaliste il doit être
politique ? politiser.
Attends, je je finis juste si tu veux un
jour savoir si tu si tu es suivi, c'est
une bonne manière. Tu sors au métro, au
moment où tu sors, tu fais bien attends
une station, il y a pas trop de monde,
ça sera plus simple. Tu regardes bien
qui sort avec toi du métro, tu essayes
de flasher un peu OK qui était là avec
moi sur ce qu'est en sortie de ce métro.
Tu prends l'escalier, tu montes, tu vas
de l'autre côté, tu reprends le métro
dans l'autre sens et là tu regardes
attentivement qui a fait la même chose
que toi de pied d'avant sur le qu
machin.
Mais ça c'est quand ils ont pas de
moyens mon pote. Parce que quand ils ont
des moyens, ils ont quatre personnes à
ton cul. T'inquiète pas, tu te
Alors j'ai je sais pas ce qui se faisait
mais depuis qu'on a des masques, il y a
vachement plus de filature physique.
Alors je sais pas si moi j'ai changé de
level dans ma fiche S machin et tout et
que du coup j'ai le droit à plus de flic
à pied fich. J'ai l'impression que
depuis que on a des masques, ils ont
plus de mal à nous capter sur les
caméras et que du coup enfin moi je vois
plus de flics physique au contact et ils
sont plus prêts que avant. Et pourtant
en ce moment,
il ressemble à quoi ? C'est il y a un
profil type, pas du tout. Des fois c'est
des grands-mères, c'est pas des
grands-mères, c'est des jeunes, pas des
jeunes.
C'est quoi le profil type selon toi du
mec qui fait de la finure d'un ARG ? Euh
c'est plutôt un mec euh
ils sont extrêmement reconnaissables à
la main de s'habiller. C'est c'est
tellement pas discret quoi. Euh billé un
peu comme toi, non ?
Hm.
Un billet un peu comme toi.
On parle d' RG là.
Ouais. Ou ouais.
Non non. Euh on on dirait des fois c'est
Sherlock Holmes quoi. Il manque juste le
chapeau quoi. Genre c'est euh ça
ressemble un peu à des vieux médecins
avec les trucs en cuir tu sais. Voilà.
Il y en a qui sont très discrets parce
qu'ils sont jeunes genre ils ont des
baskets machin. Ça dépend en fait je
pense ça dépend quel service tu as. Si
tu as euh si tu as les mecs du
commissariat du quartier qui le vieux
flic qui doit juste savoir euh où tu es
allé à l'hôtel, où est-ce que tu vas
bouffer quand tu es à Paris, euh quels
sont qu'est-ce que tu as fait quand là
tu as le RG du quartier, lui euh bon il
est pas discret. Si tu as affaire à un
mec de la DGSI un peu machin qui vient
savoir euh parce que tu vas voir un gars
dans un bar particulier avant une manife
pour avoir des informations et cetera,
là tu vas avoir à faire à RG qui est
probablement d'un level différent, d'un
service différent et lui il va être un
peu plus discret quoi. Mais mais non, en
général c'est une catastrophe. C'est
c'est la camionnette devant la porte.
C'est très drôle parce que une fois je
rentrais une manif et j'avais le casque
derrière le sac et le trottoir était
très petit. Et en fait, au moment où je
me retourne pour ouvrir la porte, mon
casque il tape le rétroviseur de de la
camion. Il est 2h du matin quoi. Il tape
le rétroviseur de la camette. J'ai pas
fait exprès mais ça fait quand même du
bruit. En fait, ils ont eu peur dans la
camionnette. Ils ont pensé peut-être
j'ai mis un coup de pied dans la porte
ou un truc et ils ont sursauté dans la
camionnette et du coup il y devait deux
ou trois et
il y a il y a les suspensions qu'on fait
comme ça. On entendait des le truc à
roulettes et tout machin. Enfin c'était
tellement pas discret quoi. Il y a une
autre fois où je suis sorti faire les
courses à 23h et pour me [__] de leur
gueule, je leurais collé un
autocollantiste sur le le cul de la de
la camionnette et le temps que je fasse
les courses que je revienne l'autocan il
était plus là. Genre ils étaient sortis
de la camionnette, ils avaient enlevé
l'autocollant puis ils étaient rerentrés
la camionnette. En fait je pense à un
moment il se cache pas. En fait, c'est
ils veulent que tu les vois en fait pour
qu'ils sachent que on t'a à l'œil, mec.
Ils se mettent devant la porte en bas de
chez toi. Un jour, il y en avait un, il
était au volant, je suis venu mais je
lui parle, il répond pas. C'est une
espèce de pression constante. Tu sais
qu'elle est là, tu sais que ils savent
tout. Mais qu'est-ce que tu veux faire ?
Tu mettes des cafés avec du lailix,
hein.
C'est une boutade. Je te repose ma
question. Est-ce qu'un journaliste doit
être politisé ?
Est-ce que c'est pas néfaste que les
journalistes soient politisés pour pour
l'information ?
Est-ce qu'il existe vraiment un
journaliste neutre ?
Tu sais que ça se fait pas de répondre à
une question par une question.
Est-ce que tu peux me citer un
journaliste neutre et je réponds à ta
question ?
Ici, ici c'est moi qui pose les
questions.
Donc non, ça n'existe pas. Donc les
journalistes doivent travailler à être
le plus neutre possible et à rapporter
de l'effet dans la plus dans leur
exactitude.
Et maintenant, peut-être que s'il y
avait assez de journalistes euh
factuels, on pourrait avoir des
journalistes politisés. Là, on a trop de
journalistes politisés et pas assez de
journalistes factuels, ça c'est clair.
Et euh maintenant, journalist politié,
c'est large. C'est-à-dire que tu peux
avoir un journaliste qui choisit ses
sujets d'une manière politique mais qui
reste totalement factuel. Tu peux avoir
un journaliste qui soit sujet d'une
manière factuelle et qui les couvre
d'une manière politique. Donc après la
question est quand même un peu large.
C'est fait exprès. Est-ce que c'est une
légende urbaine les agents perturbateurs
en manifestation ? Agents perturbateurs,
tu sais, c'est ceux qui se déguisent.
Oui, je vois.
Et en fait, c'est des flics pour faire
des contrefus pour
C'est plus compliqué que ça.
Ah, raconte.
C'està-dire que un mec qui vient qui se
déguise en black block qui prend la
banderole et qui va balancer des trucs
sur le flip "Ah les gars, on y va !"
Non, ça existe pas. Ou alors je les ai
jamais vu ou alors je suis aveugle mais
ça me semble pas crédible ça.
Ça marcherait pas. Les gens les les mecs
du bloc, ils se connaissent. Il verrait
que il Mais "Mais c'est qui celui-là ?
Il vient d'où ? Il fait quoi ? Machin et
puis voilà." Non, ça ça marcherait pas.
S'il y a des agents perturbateurs, ils
sont infiltrés bien plus en profondeur
dans les organisations. Ça veut dire que
ils sont déjà membres des organisations.
Les mecs les prennent pour dégâts
normaux en fait du bloc mais c'est des
flics. Donc c'est plutôt ça que je
considère être des agents perturbes. Ça
veut dire des mecs qui sont jeunes
infiltrés dans les organisations qui
foutent le bordel en manif et que ils
savent que s'ils sont attrapés il leur
arrivera rien puisqu'ils sont ils sont
machin. Mais par contre en échange, je
dois filer des infos. Je sais même pas
si ça existe connement. J'en ai jamais
vu. Je je te dis comment moi je le
percevrais que ça pourrait exister. Mais
euh
est-ce que ça peut être est-ce que ça
peut être aussi des puissances étrangère
qui contrôle ce type de
Alors ça oui. Euh et eux non plus des
fois sont pas très discrets. Mais euh
c'est-à-dire c'est qui eux ?
Euh j'ai j'ai envie de voyager dans ma
vie. Donc s'il te plaît on va je vais
pas répondre à cette question mais
c'est qui eux ?
Non non je passe déjà au moins 7h juste
pour aller en vacances en Italie à
l'aéroport donc ça va pitié
avec ou sans toucher rectal.
Je ne veux pas me mettre un pays à dos.
C'est bon déjà la France, c'est bon.
Mais mais clairement, j'ai vu euh
en Allemagne euh des manifestants
allemands sortir un mec en disant que
c'était un flic. Euh j'ai pas trop
compris parce qu'il parlait allemand
mais il disait "Ouais, celui-là c'est
politi alors que le mec était en bloc,
il était il" et bon est-ce que c'était
vrai ou est-ce que c'était
potentiellement
une erreur de la part de de la manif ?
Je sais pas. Donc mais je je dis je l'ai
jamais vu. Ça ça me paraît possible euh
des puissances étrangères qui
instrumentalisent ce type de mouvement.
Ah non ça mais c'est évident. Enfin là
par exemple la manifestinienne ça
m'étonnerait pas que il y ait pas mal de
renseignements israéliens qui viennent
jeter un coup d'œil voire même Qatari
voire même d'autres enfin américain
anglais. Euh Paris, c'est une ville euh
c'est une ville internationale. Donc
forcément euh quand il y a des
mouvements sociaux comme de la taille de
suite des gilets jaunes, je pense que
tous les services de renseignement des
pays euh euh de l'OTAN, ils ont dû faire
un tour quoi. C'est sûr. Déjà quand tu
vois comment les les pays, j'essaie de
bien faire ça pour pouvoir voyager
encore, comment les différentes
puissances mondiales gère l'information
via leur via leurs canaux
nationaux qu'ils importent dans les pays
machin
alors là ça peut être autant les Chinois
que les Américains que les Russes.
Voilà, c'est pour donc je reste assez
large mais
il y a déjà une tentative si tu veux de
contrôler la enfin pas contrôler mais de
d'analyser l'information sous un regard
national par des puissances étrangères
en France de la part de des principales
puissances étrangères
des exemples.
Je veux dire même la NHK japonaise elle
fait des reportages sur ce qui se passe
en France. Ils sont bien foutus de notre
gueule avec les masques d'ailleurs. Et
euh
pourquoi
hein ?
Pourquoi ? Bah parce que parce que au
Japon ils savent gérer, ils ont ils
savent gérer des masques et que quand
nous on s'est bousculé pour acheter du
PQ ou que on savait pas produire des
masses surgico, ils sont un peu moqués
de nous, ce qui était légitime. Mais euh
mais oui, enfin tu il y a plein de
médias américains qui font de
l'influence en France, il y a plein de
médias russes qui font de l'influence en
France. Il y a
médias chinois,
il y a alors les médias chinois moins
mais ils sont ils arrivent. Euh c'est
c'est plus compliqué peut-être, je sais
pas. Euh peut-être qu'on n'est pas dans
la sphère d'influence prioritaire de la
Chine. Ouais, trop petit. Mais j'ai j'ai
pas encore senti d'influence
de news de la part de la Chine soit ou
alors de quel médiia. Mais euh et la NHK
japonaise encore, je dis ça mais parce
que j'ai vu un extrême, il parle jamais
de nous quoi. les les pays qui agissent
le plus en France en terme d'influence
d'info, c'est vraiment bah les
États-Unis, la Russie,
le Qatar,
le Qatarah, les pays du Moyen-Orient
évidemment euh mais voilà, enfin
quelques pays européens comme la
Hollande, l'Allemagne et cetera,
il y a des journalistes qui se font
graisser la patte des je vais dire
journalistes mainstream qui se font un
peu graissés. Bah je suis pas j'ai pas
j'ai pas été je suis indépendant depuis
depuis 11 ans 12 ans. J'ai pas été
salarié dans la presse mainstream. J'ai
je me suis balé dans les couloirs mais
j'ai j'en ai jamais fait partie en fait
donc je peux pas te dire j'en sais rien.
Je
Comment toi tu fais pour t'informer ?
Alors euh j'ai toujours écouté France
Info et depuis tout petit hein. Euh sous
la
c'est maman qui écoutait ça dans la
cuisine
sous la douche en voiture euh machin
enfin France info. Alors après c'est je
désolé s'ils m'entendent mais ça s'est
un peu dégradé euh et ça ça m'embête
parce que c'est c'était quand même dire
que il y a 10 ans, tu pouvais écouter
France info pendant 1 heure et même si
tu avais le journal toutes les 15
minutes, ce qui était placé entre
c'était tellement intéressant que tu
pouvais écouter pendant une heure,
c'était pas répétitif, c'était
intéressant, c'était cool et tout.
Aujourd'hui, [__] déjà le foot, on
s'en fout, vous faites chier quoi. Le
rugby c'est pareil quoi. Non, si on veut
écouter des trucs de sport, on va sur
RM, c'est sport quoi. Mais en France
info c'est de l'info. Alors OK, vous
pouvez faire les résultats mais parler
du foot pendant trois qu4 d'heure. Moi
j'éteins quoi. Ça c'est c'est France
info quoi. Et il y a moins de reportages
internationaux aussi. Et mais voilà, je
reste fidèle quand même à ma radio
machin. Et en en je regarde le journal
de le France 24 en mangeant aussi parce
qu'il dure en général 12 à 15 minutes et
que c'est à peu près le temps que je
mets pour manger mon sandwich. Euh et
c'est international aussi pas mal. Donc
ça je trouve je le trouve pas mal
intéressant. Comme c'est France 24
forcément sur la politique française,
ils sont un petit peu light mais bon
forcément ils font plus de
l'international. Donc voilà. Après bon
bah ça m'arrive de regarder les les les
news un peu de je sais pas moi de
d'autres chaînes international. Euh je
parle que anglais donc je regarde pas ce
qui se passe partout dans le monde et
puis après bah Twitter quoi. Donc
forcément quand je vois passer quelque
chose, je lis l'article. Voilà. Alors,
les vieux boomers du journaliste du
journalisme les vieux boomers du
journalisme vous vous appelé
avec Réy Buine.
Euh ceux qui ont révolutionné le
journalisme, ceux qui ont un peu secoué
les les poussières journalistiques.
Toi, tu as perçu ça comment ? Pour toi,
c'était normal parce que il fallait y
aller ou parce que c'est eux qui se sont
empattés à faire perdurer le rond rond
quotidien ?
Tu parles pas assez fort parce que avec
le masque c'est compliqué.
Non, mais c'est parce que tu as pris
trop de grenadettes de désencerclement.
Pour on en parlera aussi si tu veux. Je
suis à moitié sourd. En plus, tu as le
masque donc ça va pas être facile.
Les vieux journalistes
Oui.
Euh, ils ont été obligés de se, si tu me
permets d'être vulgaire, ils ont été
obligés de se sortir les doigts du cul
un petit peu parce que vous avez un peu
ubérisé la profession d'une façon
radicale. H
vous en avez discuté, tu en as discuté
avec eux, tu as vu les papiers qu'ils
ont sortis sur toi ? Est-ce que ça leur
a fait du bien ? Est-ce que ça a fait du
bien l'information ? Je me fais ma
question Candide
innocente.
Oui, je vois bien.
Tu connais Réy ?
Je le connais très bien. Enfin, je le
connais de de l'époque où il est arrivé
sur le terrain. Aujourd'hui, je le vois
je le croise en temps en manif je l'ai
vraiment vu arriver comme une cobète. Et
on s'est une histoire très drôle, c'est
que il c'était tout au début, il il
faisait des lives sur périscope encore,
je crois et et en fait, il s'était fait
piquer ses images par absolument toute
la presse. Euh et il s'était fait péter
son téléphone ce soir-là, je crois. Il
voilà, ça été fait il s'était fait péter
son iPhone donc il avait perdu 1000
balles et il s'était fait piquer toutes
ses images de la soirée par la presse
qui avait cité son périscope et euh et
nous on avait un poil les nerf parce que
en fait en citant son tweet bah la
presse n'avait pas acheté nos piges.
Donc accessoirement Réy euh il avait
perdu beaucoup d'argent mais il nous en
avait fait perdre aussi. Alors on lui on
en voulait pas, c'était voilà mais on
allait lui expliquer, tu vois genre Ry
là en fait la M lui expliquer c'était là
en fait tu nous as pas juste fait perdre
500 € à tous, tu as perdu 5000 balles là
en fait tu as perdu 10 piges en fait
genre et si tu les avais vendu plutôt
que de les offrir tu aurais pu t'acheter
cinq iPhones et entre-temps bah il a été
repris mais si tu veux c'est marrant de
cette époque où euh on a tous commencé
quelque part moi j'ai aussi commencé à
Renn et cetera avec mon écharpe sur la
gueule et cetera mais mais ouais Ry il
est arrivé comme une fusée il est arrivé
chez Brut et je trouve qu'il a vraiment
bien évolué dans le sens où euh c'est
c'est on on
il aurait pu vraiment mal s'en sortir en
fait par rapport à son trajet, par
rapport à là d'où il vient et là où il
est aujourd'hui et il s'en est plutôt
bien tiré. Euh et je trouve que
aujourd'hui c'est Ouais, il continue à
faire du bon travail. Voilà. Après, on
peut on peut tout on a tous enfin on a
tous des aspects on peut être critiqué
et d'autres on peut être machin. Réi là,
j'ai pas particulièrement envie de
critiquer quoi. Enfin, il a fait il a
fait ce qu'il a pu et il l'a fait bien.
Donc
il y a une solidarité chez les
journalistes
hein.
Il y a une solidarité chez les les
journalistes.
Ça dépend chez qui. Je pense c'est ceux
qui vont sur le terrain. Ouais. Ser les
coudes.
On sait on se connaît parce qu'on se on
se voit déjà et puis on sait ce qu'on
prend quoi. On a tous un peu les mêmes
euh les mêmes blessures, les mêmes
problèmes machin. Donc voilà. Et euh
mais après bon le mais ça c'est c'est
aussi Paris mais le milieu de le milieu
de journée c'est un milieu cruel mais
c'est la même chose pour les
communicants milieux cruel
hein.
Pourquoi un milieu cruel ?
Mais c'est c'est les relations humaines.
Je veux dire c'est c'est mais ça c'est
Paris en fait c'est tu retrouves ça dans
toutes les les professions tircières en
fait. C'est la concurrence est tellement
forte entre les gens, c'est tellement
difficile d'arriver quelque part, de se
faire un nom, de de pas se faire [__]
de défendre son son biftech, d'arriver à
s'en sortir
que à un moment en fait les places sont
tellement chères
que les gens sont vraiment à cran.
Ensuite
cher pour gagner peins.
Ah bah le journaliste c'est j'ai fait
beaucoup rire mon père avec qui j'ai ça
hier soir, mais c'était ma mère. Mais
euh après justement très flippé par
rapport au fait que je je fasse cette
interview, mais euh
pourquoi
et je disais oui, c'est journaliste,
c'est la profession la moins rentable du
monde quoi en fait. Genre là, je suis à
Paris, je paye l'hôtel. Euh alors pour
le coup, j'ai miracle, ça n'arrive
jamais. J'ai vendu mes piges avant de
venir à Paris. Donc là, je sais que le
montant de mes piges pour les deux
manivres que j'ai couvertes couvre
l'hôtel, la bouffe, le métro et le
billet de train aller retour. Donc en
gros ce que j'ai gagné là pour la
manifalestine et celle de demain devant
l'Assemblé nationale, c'est ce que j'ai
dépensé pour pouvoir le faire. J'ai
gagné zéro en fait. Je suis venu, j'ai
dépensé de l'argent que j'ai gagné pour
pouvoir travailler en fait. Et ça fait
12 ans que je suis journaliste et je
m'en suis bien tiré cette fois-ci parce
que j'ai eu une pige avant de partir. Ça
aurait très bien pu être je viens une
semaine à Paris, je vais à l'hôtel, je
paye le métro, je paye le machin, je
vends rien, je rentre à Strasbourg et
puis bah j'attends le début du mois
prochain pour avoir un peu de don.
D'ailleurs, si les gens veulent faire
des dons à Taranis, c'est Tipi, vous
pouvez y aller. Là, en plus, Ulis vient
de se mettre à faire des photos
argentiques avec des pellicules, donc ça
va coûter cher. Mais oui, non, enfin,
tipi.com Taranis, c'est le logo avec un
squal noir designé.
Allez-y. En fait, à la base, c'était
très drôle parce à la base, on voulait
faire voler des drones
et à cette époque, c'était pas encore
des cours décrypteures, c'était des des
ailes en V. Et en fait, ça devait être
un un drone avec des yeux en fait à la
base, mais tout le monde y a vu un
requin parce qu'en plus on était à Renn
à ce moment-là. Bon, c'est devenu un
requin. Euh voilà. Taranis à la base
c'est le dieu cel du tonner euh du feu,
de la guerre. Enfin voilà, c'était le
c'était le seul dieu Celt dont le nom de
n'était pas déposé à Linp en fait.
Voilà.
Pourquoi ta mère, elle avait elle avait
peur que tu viennes ici ?
Non, mais c'est familial. C'est c'est
tous mes potes, t tous mes amis, ils ont
peur. C'est il faut pas que je fasse
d'interview, c'est une catastrophe.
Pourquoi ?
Bah j'aime pas ça déjà. Et puis voilà,
je déjà je parle trop, ensuite je dis
plein de conneries et euh enfin voilà.
Mais je t'ai accordé cette je dis
vraiment je dis non à toutes les quand
j'ai été mis en garde à vue, j'ai dit
oui pendant une semaine parce qu'il y
avait une mobilisation nationale pour me
faire sortir que c'était absolument
incroyable et que je pouvais pas ne pas
rendre ce qu'on m'avait donné ça. Enfin
j'ai dit oui à tout le monde pendant une
semaine 7 jours et après de bah en fait
depuis j'ai absolument pas fait
d'interview donc depuis fin avril 2019
et donc tu es le premier à qui j'accorde
l'intervie.
Et pourquoi pourquoi ici ?
Pourquoi je suis venu ?
h la situation s'grave et ça va pas
s'améliorer. Et de la même manière dont
je suis déjà revenu auprès d'interviewer
dans ce cadre là, je je me je me
rappelle un petit peu à l'existence de
des gens en disant voilà
on va beaucoup travailler dans les
prochains temps. On est toujours là,
on est en place et voilà si je sais pas
comment le décrire mais c'est une forme
de voilà c'est on travaille pour vous
aussi. Donc c'est normal que de temps en
temps bah on puisse me poser des
questions, je puisse y répondre. Voilà,
s'il y a des gens qui posent des
questions dans le chat, nésitez pas à
les transmettre. Mais euh enfin voilà,
je
j'ai le sentiment que de temps en temps
il faut revenir un peu auprès de son
audience quand même pour rendre des
comptes quoi. En fait, si tous les
journalistes faisait ça, serait bien.
Gérald Gérald Armanin qui va en
manifestation demain.
C'est normal, c'est pas normal. Vous
allez le couvrir, vous allez pas le
couvrir ? Est-ce que c'est une façon
d'éviter ?
C'est c'est une reprise politique. C'est
c'est un coup de buzz à la Nicolas
Sarkozy. C'est c'est quoi
Gérald ?
Il a des petits air non de ministre de
l'intérieur sarcosiste. Non,
moi je l'appelle Nicolas Darman euh mais
alors non, il me semble que c'est le
premier ministre qui vient manifester
devant l'Assemblée nationale de puis je
sais même pas quand depuis la
J'ai pas trouvé de j'ai pas trouvé de de
passif.
Euh
je je sais pas, je je vois pas l'intérêt
politique. Enfin si à la limite
l'intérêt politique auprès de
l'électorat policier, oui, auprès
d'électorat de droite voire d'extrême
droite à la limite. Mais l'électorat
collectif, celui justement qui de toute
façon ne votera pas pour enfin qui ne
voterait pas à la base pour les pour la
droite mais qui pourrait le faire sera
pas convaincu par la présence du
ministre de l'intérieur devant
l'Assemblée. Ça n'a pas de sens en fait
et surtout ça envoie un message
horrible. On sait très bien que les
syndicats policiers pour certains euh
mais c'est juste une poubelle à fasciste
quoi. Je suis désolé de le dire mais
c'est ça quoi.
Faut pas faut pas dire ça.
Non mais non mais si enfin ils regardent
leur compte Twitter euh ils se
permettent de dire des choses parce
qu'ils sont au syndicat de police, ils
sont pas flashés de Twitter et et
bannis. Alors que si c'était n'importe
quel troll d'extrême droite, ça serait
le cas. Ça veut dire que à un moment il
y a il y a il y a des syndicats de
police qui disent des choses sur
Twitter, c'est inacceptable.
Tu as un exemple à me proposer ? Non,
j'ai pas envie de les citer jamais de la
vie. Surtout pas de leur faire de la pub
ou quoi que ce soit. Mais à un moment,
tu peux pas affirmer ça comme ça. Il
faut donner un exemple. Ça c'est notre
enfin va sur Twitter, chope les
syndicats de police, fou, tu trouveras
tout ce que tu veux. En 10 minutes, tu
en auras trouvé plusieurs. Genre je je
et on a déjà réagi par rapport à ça.
Enfin genre c'est la la manière dont
dont les syndicats de police
communiquent. Je trouve pas seulement ça
extrêmement agressif. Qu'un syndicat
soit offensif, c'est son boulot. Qu'un
syndicat défende sa profession, c'est
son job. euh que les que la CGT Gino ça
soit des ch autant que la CGT police,
c'est ça enfin c'est normal, enfin c'est
un syndicat. Maintenant euh
l'extrême droite euh
c'est pas une valeur du syndicalisme
quoi. Ça l'a jamais été je crois et ça
le sera jamais. Ça n'a pas ça c'est ça
ça colle pas en fait. Ça ça peut pas se
brancher en fait. C'est une prise
européenne avec une prise américaine
quoi. Ça ça non ça rentre pas. Donc
quand les syndicats de police sont
permis par leur hiérarchie d'avoir un
discours ouvertement d'extrême droite en
ligne dans leur manif parfois auprès des
caméras quand des policiers manifestent
avec leur flingue à la ceinture alors
qu'ils sont pas en service.
Moi j'ai du mal. Je et je considère pas
que c'est prendre partie ou quoi que ce
soit. quand je le vois, je le filme, je
les interview comme si c'était d'autres
manifestants. Mais franchement ça c'est
ça ça me ferait bizarre de n'importe qui
de voir une manif avec des mecs armé
quoi. Enfin à un moment c'était il y a
quelques temps maintenant mais euh il
manifestait sur les Champs éélysées avec
leur flingue quoi. L'interview du mec
sous les Champs-Élysées du flic sous
l'Arc de Triomphe, il a son gun à
l'aventure.
Ça devient un petit peu inquiétant la
France quoi. Donc voilà.
Est-ce que tu as Est-ce que tu as Est-ce
que tu peux me trouver trois qualités de
la police nationale et de la gendarmerie
?
Alors, je pense que ça va faire plein de
personnes ce que je veux dire. Mais on a
besoin d'une police dans un pays en
fait.
On a besoin d'une police dans un pays.
C'est
c'est la manière dont la police
française
a été euh
comment shape en anglais, mais je même
plus le mot en français euh façonné au
fur et à mesure du 20e siècle qu'on en
est arrivé là où on est. Mais euh il me
semble qu'il y a des pays où la police
se comporte mieux qu'en France et où ça
se passe foutrement mieux que chez nous.
Il y a pas beaucoup de pays où ça se
passe extrêmement bien, c'est pas ce que
je dis. Mais par contre, clairement, on
n'est pas les meilleurs, quoi. Et c'est
pas forcément de la faute du fait que
les Français sont un peuple
ingouvernable. C'est aussi euh du fait
que sa police euh
colle pas euh ou alors euh enfin, je
sais pas, mais il y a tu tu m'as demandé
trois qualités, c'est ça ?
leur réactivité
quand à un moment
on a besoin d'eux et que ils doivent
être là, ils sont réactifs. Donc c'est
une de leurs qualités.
C'est une question dégueulasse. Tu me
faire [__] tu es vraiment monstre. Et
deuxième qualité de la police nationale.
Ah, ils ont un très bon armement, ils
sont très bien équipés. J'ai gagné
trè qualité.
le rapport humain. Non. Ah
non,
sûrement pas. Euh,
ils sont polis, ils sont efficaces.
Non, sûrement pas. Absolument pas.
Catastrophe. [__] alors là, ils sont
vraiment pas efficaces. Euh, excuse-moi,
mais il y avait combien de policiers
samedi ? 4200.
devait y avoir maximum 1000
manifestants. Ça a été un des pires bull
de l'année quoi.
Parce que la manif était interdite.
C'était pas la faute des manifestants
mais ils auraient mis 100 flics pour
entourer une manifique de Barbess à
Basti, ça se serait très bien passé.
Est-ce que tu les as vu ? Et tu les as
vu ? Ils ont commencé, ils avaient pas
les casques. Ils
av manifesté interdite déjà c'était sûr.
Ouais mais ils ont commencé, ils avaient
pas les casques. On était même pas
encore arrivé. Le cano était déjà en
route.
Ah ouais à 14 le manif était à 13h 14h.
On est arrivé genre un quart d'heure
avant le truc était les gens se
faisaient déjà arroser quoi. Il y avait
déjà du gaz partout. Voilà la manif
était interdite. Après le le de toute
façon il me déteste mais c'est
réciproque. Mais le préfet de l'Allemand
il
réciproque.
Le préfet de l'Allemand il a
Pourquoi c'est réciproque ?
Je parle du préfet de l'Allemand. Je je
oui je le déteste. Je c'est pas
personnel, c'est professionnel. Il m'en
a c'est il m'en a fait tellement baver
que c'est normal que je le déteste. Mais
euh
est-ce que tu fouillais trop la merde.
Bah
écoute, je sais pas pourquoi il me
déteste mais moi je sais pourquoi je le
déteste en tout cas. Mais et ce qu'il a
ce qu'il a imposé comme doctrine là ces
derniers mois, ces dernières années, euh
c'est même pas que ça va trop loin,
c'est même pas que c'est pas dans nos
lois, c'est même pas que c'est dans nos
codes, c'est même pas que c'est dans
notre culture, c'est que
c'est complètement contreproductif.
et je comprends pas qu'il l'ai pas
encore compris en fait. En radicalisant
les gens, tu les fais pas rentrer à la
maison. OK, momentanément, il y a moins
de gens dans la rue, il en reste
quelques-uns, ils sont plus radicaux,
d'accord ? Mais tu radicalises la masse.
C'estàdire que c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé, je te le racontais tout à
l'heure, entre les étudiants de 2012 et
les étudiants de 2021. En 2012, ils
avaient leur pack, leur basket, ils
étaient sans masque et puis ils y
allaient et puis voilà, ils balançaient
des poubelles. Aujourd'hui, c'est c'est
des Terminators alors que ils ont le
même âge. Euh si on continue en France à
pousser la violence policière comme elle
a lieu en ce moment, et ben ça va encore
s'agerver. les policiers vont devenir
encore plus violents, les manifestants
vont devenir encore plus violents. Et
donc voilà ce que cette politique de de
rajouter de la violence à la violence
qu'utilise l'allemand, d'interdire tout
pour rien, de de mettre 4200 flics quand
il y a 400 manifestants et cetera, ça ne
peut pas ni régler la situation, ni
éviter que des violences aient lieu dans
une manif, que ce soit entre
manifestants, contre la police, contre
des biens, je sais pas, contre n'importe
quoi. Ça ne rajouter des armes, des gens
armés, casqués, du gaz d'accrymogène et
des grenades à une situation. Je vois
pas comment est-ce que ça peut
l'améliorer en fait. Je ne comprends
pas.
Est-ce que tu as vu notre interview de
Christophe de Loir qui dit de reporter
sans
euh qui ça ?
Christophe de Loir.
Connaî pas.
Est-ce que tu l'as vu la vidéo ?
Je l'ai vu, je l'ai regardé. Est-ce que
tu veux mettre un mot sur cette
interview parce que tu as été cité
et je me dois je me doute de te donner
la parole si tu veux répondre. En fait,
je suis embêté parce que dans cette
histoire, on parle de RSF, reporter sans
frontière et dans ma carrière, j'ai
oublié de raconter un élément important,
c'est que la personne qui m'a convaincu
de faire une SARL plutôt que de rester
journaliste indépendant, c'est Pierre
Asski au moment où il était rédacteur en
chef de R 89 qui n'était pas encore
acheté par le Nouvels et d'ailleurs
même, on devait être rue 89 Rennen, mais
ça n'est pas arrivé parce que une
semaine avant que ça se produise, ils
ont été rachetés par le nouvel
observateur et ils ont annulé toutes les
ouvertures de 89 locales.
Donc d'une certaine manière par divers
rendez-vous, il y en a eu quatre ou
cinq. Pierre Asqui m'a donné des
conseils, il m'a il m'a dit de faire c,
il m'a dit de faire ça et cetera. Et
c'était des très bons conseils. Enfin,
c'était euh des conseils techniques sur
euh la construction d'entreprise, la
gestion d'une équipe. Voilà. Et
aujourd'hui, aujourd'hui Pierre Rasky
est le président de Reportage, même si à
Mon jamais. Euh je lui ai envoyé les
photos de mes blessures euh en décembre
2019 par télégra parce que j'ai encore
son numéro et en lui disant "Ça va euh
tu attends que je sois mort pour euh
pour faire une déclaration ou genre là
je je je saigne de partout, j'ai même
plus de pensement tellement euh et vous
avez même pas dit un truc quoi. Et donc
oui de loir donc oui tout pour finir
avec Attends attendsends. Donc il t'a
t'as envoyé ses photos et il t'a répondu
ou pas ?
Alors non il m'a pas répondu et il ne
m'a jamais répondu donc je pense que
est-ce que tu as vu qu'il avait consulté
le message ? il avait consulté, il avait
lu
il avait lu les messages. Donc il a vu
les messages mais il n'a pas répondu et
euh à mon grand regarder parce que bon
je pense qu'il avait peur que ça soit
publié mais si tu veux voilà c'est pas
le que j'ai connu le ASKI président de
reportage frontière et ça j'espère qu'il
entendra ça de ma part c'està dire que
le haski que j'ai connu
c'était un vrai journaliste. Là,
il est temps d'aller à la retraite
maintenant. Si c'est pour faire ça en
France, alors avec tout ce qu'on a pris
de nous de faire comme si on nexistait
pas juste pour pouvoir avoir des
subventions, alors il est il est temps
de s'arrêter quoi. Pourquoi tu dis juste
pour avoir des subventions ? Attends
reporter sans frontières
avant qu'il y ait le clash avec de Loir
trouve-moi une fois où ils ont réagi,
tweeté,
publié un communiqué de presse sur un
blessé journaliste en manif en France.
Il a fallu qu'on clashe au point que
l'autre il nous fasse une semi crise de
panique ici même sur ce sujet pour que
il se mettent un petit peu de temps en
temps à dire "Bon là vous avez mis un
journaliste en garde à vue, c'est pas
bien là le journaliste syrien qui s'est
fait exploser la gueule dans une manif
pour la liberté
hein." Non mais bon ils font le minimum
syndical mais ils ont pas dégradé la
place de la France dans leur classement
? Euh si 33 ou
ouais enfin on est passé de 34 à 33 s'il
te plaît enfin quand tu vois ce qu'on a
j'ai des j'ai des potes journalistes qui
ont perdu des doigts. J'ai des potes
journalistes qu' ont perdu des des enfin
on a tous des cicatrices.
Tu veux montrer une de tes photos que tu
m'as montré avant là à la caméra ?
Montre-nous.
Oui si tu veux. Non, enfin mon téléphone
fond de ma poche. Mais
attention le micro
mais je les avais publié hein. C'était
les photos de mes cuisses. Rie-toi.
Alors
désolé les cadreurs vous allez galérer
hein. Ah ça c'était ma cuisse gauche. Tu
montes un peu ton téléphone.
C'est bon.
Est-ce que tu peux me faire un petit
zoom ? Merci.
En fait la trace bleue c'est mon
téléphone que comme j'avais pris quatre
plots dans le téléphone ça avait appuyé
sur la cuisse au point de faire ça.
C'est bon là ?
Ouais ouais d'autre
ça c'est les trois plotes de désencer.
Donc là c'est cramé machin. Ça c'était
la cuisse gauche.
Donc ça tu as envoyé ça à Pierreaski.
Et ça c'est Ouais. Et ça c'était la
cuisse droite. C'est ça que je l'ai
envoyé.
Voilà. Donc en gros, ça fait ça te fait
un ça te fait un trou comme ça. Et là
encore, ah je précise, là j'ai deux
pantalons de chantier, hein. Donc euh
c'est des trucs qui sont antifeu qui
sont prévenus contre les explosions
machin. Normalement là, j'ai de la
chance si ça avait été un pantalon en
tissu, ça aurait fait un trou pire que
ça quoi. Mais en gros, voilà, ça euh
c'est Ah oui, si tu veux, ça c'est
l'état de mon téléphone aussi après.
Donc euh voilà, devant et derrière.
Et d'ailleurs, j'avais retiré ça.
C'était un éclat du verre de du verre de
mon iPhone de l'intérieur de ma cuisse.
J'avais j'avais pu le retirer de Non
mais c'est fantastique he les grenades.
D'ailleurs, elles ont changé, maintenant
elles sont encore mieux. Ils ont un
nouveau modèle.
Revenons à RSF.
Oui. Bah
en fait, je pense qu'on a mis le doigt
là où ça fait mal, mais on l'a pas fait
pour faire chier.
Peux-tu parler de subvention ? Oui, par
leur subvention à un moment il qui
finance RSF
qui com le salaire du dollar c'est qui
qui le paye ? C'est toi ? C'est moi. Ils
sont financés par l'État. Donc à un
moment c'est logique qu'ils aient du mal
à taper sur l'État français parce qu'ils
ont peur qu'on leur réduise leur
subvention. C'est aussi simple que ça,
il me semble. Sinon, explique-moi ce que
c'est d'autre. Pourquoi est-ce que un
moment quand un journaliste est blessé
dans une manifestation en Turquie, il y
a une meilleure couverture de ce qui se
passe que quand il est blessé à Paris en
bas de leur [__] de bureau, quoi ?
Pourquoi ? Quand à un moment il y a un
journaliste qui fait 48 he et je parle
pas de moi là qui fait 48 he de garde à
vue, un jour de dépôt qui passe au
tribunal machin qui est ressorti parce
qu'il a rien fait pas un mot. Pourquoi
est-ce que quand il y a des mecs à
l'hôpital machin ? un pourquoi un moment
pourquoi est-ce qu'il a fallu qu'on les
clashe frontalement, qu'on mette nos
carrières en jeu parce queon nous passe
encore pour défou à gueuler sur Twitter
et cetera pour que un moment bon de
temps en temps un petit communiqué, un
petit tweet pour montrer que voilà on a
le petit soutien mais au final bon la
vérité c'est que
le soutien on l'attend encore quoi. Ils
sont où les avocats financés par essai ?
Moi les avocats je les paye quand je
vais en garde à vue. Enfin un moment ce
serait peut-être du rôle de RSF de
défendre le journaliste quand ils sont
rien fait. Tu
peux comprendre ? Est-ce que tu peux
comprendre aussi que lui, un journaliste
qui fait un doigt d'honneur parce que
bon, il s'est fait pousser, il s'est
fait prendre une grenade, bon bah ça le
fait pas. Un journaliste, il doit pas
faire un doigt d'honneur, il doit pas
être turbulent comme ça.
Mais ça c'était un contexte qui était
particulier. Enfin, je l'ai mis dans la
vidéo la la 5 secondes avant, il y a le
commissaire en chef, genre le
commissaire divisionnaire, le mec qui
gère toute la place de la République
quoi. Il vient me voir, fait "Bonjour
Gaspar, ça va ?" Genre, et je n'ai chez
ma GoPro, je suis en train de le filmer
et je et je je dis à mon binô [__] ça
va, il m'appelle pas mon prénom, quoi.
Ça m'a même fait rire. Et je lui
réponds, je fais "Oui, bah oui, ça va.
Oui, je travaille quoi." Et euh mais
vraiment 5 secondes, je je j'avance, je
me retourne Grenade et c'était le mec de
son unité qui m'avait vu dire bonjour au
commissaire divisionnaire.
Je et je me la prends dans les jambes et
je me prends un plot dans dans avec un
un bon gnac dans dans le genou.
Il y a beaucoup de journalistes qui sont
blessés en manifestation en France. Il y
a beaucoup de journalistes qui sont
blessés en manifestation.
Oui, il y en a beaucoup. Il y en a trop
de toute façon mais il y en a beaucoup.
Oui, enfin je te dis je connais pas, il
me semble pas connaître des journalistes
qui est couvert des le mouvement des
gilets jaunes pour nous citer que lui
qui a pas de blessure. En fait, on a
tous au moins pris un truc quoi. Enfin,
le dégâts matériel, j'en parle même pas.
Quand tu tombes par terre parce que tu
t'es fait exploser par un CRS avec son
bouclier, tu pètes ton micro jack, ta
caméra elle est foutue. Quand je me suis
pris la grenade avec les photos que tu
as vu, je suis tombé par terre sur sur
la caméra, elle est morte. Je suis tombé
sur l'objectif, il explosé. Donc c'est
fini. euh c'est 3000 € d'un coup.
Euh 3000 € à un moment quand tu es
journaliste euh bah tu mets 3 4 mois
avant de pouvoir la repayer. Donc tu
mets 3 4 mois avant de pouvoir
retravailler.
Question d'internet de Filou 88. Est-ce
que est-ce que tu as déjà eu peur pour
ta vie ?
Ah oui.
Ah oui carrément à plusieurs reprises.
Du genre
la grenade dans les jambes là. En fait
le truc c'est que quand tu prends le
blast d'une grenade désancerclante mais
vraiment très près à 1 m autour de toi,
tu as l'effet blast. ce que je ne
connaissais pas mais que qui c'est
vraiment pas rien. C'est en fait tu per
en fait tu perds l'équilibre
instantanément tu tombes par terre.
C'est même pas que tu as tu tes jambes
tu déjà tu les sens plus donc tu te
demandes si elles sont encore là déjà et
tu n'arrives plus à à tenir debout
puisque tu tes jambes elles sont elles
sont pas machin. Donc tu tombes par
terre et momentanément tu as l'effet de
choc. Tu as bon les grenades pètent pas
à hauteur de tête donc tu as pas l'effet
blast dans les oreilles mais c'est
plutôt en général sur les jambes puisque
c'est au niveau du sol. Mais en plus,
souvent tu as pris des plots donc tu as
des tu as des gros impacts. Mais euh
mais clairement c'est ça, c'est vraiment
cette espèce de période de 5 à 10
secondes euh où tu as eu le blast et où
tu te dis bon c'est quoi les dégâts quoi
? Euh c'est tu es dans l'avion, tu es tu
es tu viens tu as entendu boum et tu es
là OK copilote évaluation des dégâts.
Est-ce qu'il reste un réacteur ? Est-ce
qu'on a encore les flaps ? C'est à peu
près ça quoi. Et le flashball c'est
moins pire parce que tu l'entends partir
et et tu entends l'impact et puis tu
enfin c'est comme une balle quoi. C'est
moi le flashball j'ai eu de la chance de
m'en prendre que dans les pieds ou dans
le cul donc ou dans le sac donc ça a pas
été trop grave mais non l'effet blasse
des grenades ouais c'est bah tu peux pas
marcher pendant 3 minutes quoi. Tu tu
arrives pas à te relever. Tu tes jambes
elles veulent pas elles fonctionnent pas
en fait. Voilà.
Question internet. Indépendant. Oui.
Mais comment est-il financé ? bah les
dons euh et ensuite bah principalement
la vente de piges, c'est-à-dire bah
quand tu finis un quand vous voyez un
reportage sur Teranis, euh c'est le
contenu qui est envoyé euh aux
différents médias et eux peuvent acheter
un morceau. Euh en général, ils achètent
pas le reportage entier, ils prennent un
morceau de 1 minute à 1 minute 30 et ils
le payent en certains tarifs. Et euh
donc mes piges personnels, je l'ai
réinvesti dans mes reportages. Les dons,
bah c'est les reportages, c'est les
serveurs, c'est les caméras, c'est les
disques durs, c'est bientôt les
pellicules de Ulis,
c'est les déplacements, les hôtels, les
trains, les locations de voiture,
les caméras pétées, euh les cartes SD de
400 Go euh enfin genre passer des
meilleurs. Là, bientôt, ça va falloir
acheter un MacBook, ça va coûter une
fortune. Voilà. Donc les dons, c'est
extrêmement important pour faire
fonctionner la presse. Ça, je le dis
pour moi, mais en fait, je le dis pour
tout le monde. Si vous si vous voulez de
l'information,
faites-vous une petite sélection. Quit à
plutôt c'est horrible ce que je dis,
plutôt que donner 15 € à un média,
donner 5 € à 3 médias, quoi. Mais mais
allez-y parce que ça sert vraiment.
Genre là, si je peux être là à Paris
cette semaine, c'est grâce au don. Euh
si je peux couvrir la manife pro
Palestine, si je peux couvrir la manif
avec Darmanin demain, c'est grâce au
don. Euh à la fin de la semaine, il y en
a ça sera épuisé. Et ben je dois je
devrais rentrer, j'ai plus d'argent,
c'est fini. Donc il va falloir attendre
la début du mois de juin pour que je
puisse repartir en portage.
Viens dormir à la maison.
J'ai pas compris.
C'est gentil. Merci.
Question internet. Est-ce qu'il y a déjà
eu des tentatives de récupération de sa
personne par des médias mainstream ou
alternatifs ?
Comment ça des tentatives de
récupération ?
proposer une petite ça ils ont tous
essayé en fait c'est c'est c'est
vraiment dégueulasse parce que manière
dont c'est fait
c'est le mieux de la communication j'ai
pas c'est pas juste le journalisme mais
on te fait d'abord croire que c'est
formidable ce que tu fais que vraiment
c'est unique tu vois on a vraiment
besoin de toi pour faire un truc tout
nouveau machin fantastique et cetera en
fait c'est pas vrai en fait on a juste
envie de te payer 500 balles par mois
pour qu'on voit ta gueule sur ce média
que tu ramènes tes followers que tu
retweetes ce que ce que le truc du
médiat Et c'est tout. C'est c'est ta
irréputation qu'on achète. C'est pas ton
travail, tu vois. Et ça c'est tout le
temps
95 % des propositions de job que j'ai
eu. C'est ça.
Ça c'est en fait ça c'est c'est à la
base c'était pas ça mais ça a fini par
se révéler être ça et c'est fatiguant
parce que du coup pendant une période où
toi
qui est-ce qui a essayé de faire ça ? Je
je peux pas dire ça mais mais par contre
c'est fatiguant parce qu'il y a une
période où tu te dis [__] je vais
avoir un job [__] c'est bon là il y a
quelqu'un qui s'intéresse à moi. Bon, ça
parce que pour moi ça veut dire salaire,
parce que pour moi ça veut dire carte de
presse, parce que pour moi ça y est,
c'est bon. Tu vois c'est je suis arrivé
au truc et à chaque fois je me rends
compte qu'en fait non ce qu'ils veulent
c'est juste un retweet, c'est juste un
article par mois pour dire voilà le
Gaspar Glans il est chez nous machin et
cetera.
Et c'est arrivé souvent et c'est arrivé
dans toute ma carrière. C'est pas
seulement parce qu'aujourd'hui j'ai plus
d'audience que il y a 5 à 10 ans. Au
début de ma carrière, ça m'arrivait
aussi dire que on fait ça sur de jeunes
journalistes parce qu'ils sont moins
chers. un un un journaliste, un
photographe aujourd'hui qui a 20000 300
40000 50000 followers sur Twitter, ils
vont lui faire ça ils vont aller le
voir, il ouais photo, c'est les
meilleurs du monde machin [__] oh là
là oh là là vraiment et tout machin on
va te filer 2000 balles machin mais mais
ils s'en foutent ils les font même pas
travailler en fait c'est juste c'est
juste pour qu'il soit là voilà pour
qu'on dise on a des jeunes dans l'équipe
question internet Gaspar envisages-tu de
faire des grands reportages à la Albert
Londres ? J'aimerais bien, j'en rêverai.
Mais si vous saviez comment ça coûte,
[__] Euh oui, bah je pense que tous
journaliste rêve de voyager, rêve de
faire des journalistes, des Moi,
j'aimerais bien aller dans l'espace euh
depuis que je suis tout petit, je
voulais être astronaute et donc
j'aimerais bien finit par y aller à un
moment. Tu as vomi tes grandes flexon
Musk son jour pour aller sur Mars sur la
lune, j'y vais tout de suite. Je suis
pas de problème, je signe. Je sais, je
crois qu' je suis peut-être un peu grand
mais tout le monde rêve d'être
astronaute.
Question d'internet, il a pensé quoi de
la tribune des militaires ? H
il faut savoir que dans ma famille euh
il y a eu un mort pour la France dans
les trois dernières guerres.
Quand je dis trois dernières guerres,
c'est 1870, 1914 et 1939 45. Euh c'est
pas une famille militaire du tout
machin. Mon père, il a pas fait son
service machin et cetera. Euh mais euh
si tu veux, c'est pas c'est pas un
milieu contre lequel on a quoi que ce
soit dans la famille puisque bah c'était
des appelés he ils ont pas fait la
guerre parce qu'ils étaient engagés.
Enfin, ils étaient pas volontaires. On
on les a cherché, on leur a dit va tirer
sur les Allemands et puis voilà. et on
leur a dit "Défends ton pays."
Mais bref, si tu veux il y a pas de
d'animosité particulière
pour les militaires. J'avais fait des
reportages, il y a une énorme présente
militaire à Renn parce qu'il y a plein
de bases, notamment Arien et cetera.
J'avais fait des reportages avec, je
crois, l'aéroporté euh à l'époque où où
je bossais en local et euh et j'avais
pas du tout trouvé la même ambiance. Euh
je trouve que l'ambiance tu peux trouver
dans les au sein des militaires, ça
ressemble vachement chez les pompiers.
Je sais pas si tu vois la différence
avec la police.
C'est c'est j'ai été énormément en garde
à vue. J'ai énormément pu observer les
policiers entre eux et faire une espèce
de sociologue dans ton canapé, tu vois,
dans sur ton banc là avec tes menottes à
observer les
c'est pas du tout pareil. C'est un monde
c'est c'est quand quand tu vois la
tribun au campagil, faut aller au
campagnil pour faire la sociologie.
Mais c'est mais c'est ce truc c'est
fantastique. Enfin genre c'est un des
moments les plus drôles de notre
carrière parce qu'on pensait vraiment
être des James Bond mais bon bref. Mais
la tribune est militaire. Oui, j'ai
couvert un des signataires, un des
premiers un des mecs qui potentiellement
écrit cette tribune, c'est le fameux
général Picmal qui justement était aller
à Calé. Cette manifestation avait été
interdite par la préfecture
et il avait été arrêté par par la police
machin et cetera. Et ça avait déjà fait
scandale à l'époque. Et les militaires à
l'époque avaient déjà dit "Non mais lui,
il l'avait révoqué d'ailleurs à cause de
ça." C'est-à-dire que à la suite de la
manifestation qu'il avait organisé à
Calé contre les migrants mais
overfasciste, il y a aucun doute
là-dessus. les mecs qui étaient c'était
c'était la crème, il y avait Benedéti je
crois, un truc comme ça machin. Enfin
bref, euh il a été révoqué de l'armée
genre 6 mois plus tard à cause de ça
alors qu'il était déjà à la retraite, tu
vois. Ils l'ont révoqué. Donc la la
tribune des militaire déjà, elle est
adoné.
Tu emplois à dessin le mot fasciste ou
ou c'est ça sort d'où ?
Non, en ce moment ça revient à la mode,
on peut Non.
Ouais, mais c'est sorti à toutes les
sources.
Non, je trouve que justement ça revient
à la mode. Enfin, ça revient dans la
société. Donc il c'est un adjectif en
fait. on s'en sert pour illustrer.
Voilà, je la la tribune dans des
militaires, elle est pas elle est pas
très de gauche quoi. Enfin, je sais pas
comment tu veux l'appeler mais c'est pas
ils se sont en général quand un enfin
c'est une forme de tentative de coup
d'état militaire. Ça c'est fasciste.
Enfin, on rentre dans la définition du
fascisme là. Non mais faut arrêter.
Non mais les mecs ils menacent d'un coup
d'état militaire. C'est ce qu'ils
disent.
Ils disent ils disent qu'ils vont être
obligés de faire le ménage avec les
conneries que les politiques font.
Enfin, de toute façon, euh des mecs qui
ont pas les couilles d'y aller
anonymement ça, sur ce sur ça, le
ministre, il avait raison.
À quoi ça sert ?
La protection des sources chez les
journalistes.
Ouais, mais là c'est une tribune.
Si tu une tribune, c'est pas pareil.
C'est Et surtout que les mecs, ils ont
le devoir de réserve. S'ils ont les
couilles de donner leur nom, c'est pas
pareil. Tu vois, genre un moment si tu
penses vraiment que que la France elle
est au bord du gouffre, que des hordes
de zombies islamogauchistes vont sortir
de Saint-Touin pour attaquer le
périphérique machin et qu'il faut que tu
prennes ta ton char d'assaut pour le
mettre sur la porte de Saintin pour
tirer sur ses hordes de sauvage et
cetera, bah tu donnes ton nom quoi. Tu
fais pas une tribune anonyme dans les
valeurs actuelles. C'est quoi ça ? Enfin
ou alors tu es pas très courageux. C'est
mon opinion. Et pour une fois, c'est la
même que celle du ministre. Je trouve ça
assez drôle mais voilà.
Est-ce que tu pourrais exercer alors
question d'internet, est-ce que tu
pourrais exercer à Gaza ? Euh bah non,
puisqu'on peut pas rentrer.
Donc euh ça répond à la question.
Et euh non, on ne peut pas rentrer. Il
ne laisse pas rentrer les journalistes.
Donc en 2014, apparemment les
journalistes pouvaient rentrer, ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui. Et euh
non, mais comme en France, la situation
avec la presse s'aggrave, j'ai le
sentiment que c'est un peu pareil dans
le monde quand c'est en Chine, en
Palestine.
Enfin, c'est la la presse à cause de le
développement des réseaux sociaux, des
vidéos et cetera, est devenu un acteur
soudainement enfin plus important dans
le débat politique peut-être. Et du
coup, bah sur qui on met plus de
pression quoi.
Question internet. Est-il fier d'être
français ?
Est-ce que je suis fier d'être en France
?
Est-ce que tu es fier d'être français ?
C'est c'est quoi cette question ?
Alors, la question c'est est-il fier
d'être français entre parenthèses pour
lui faire gagner des points côté
nationaliste ? fermer la parenthèse.
Bah déjà, je suis né à Strasbourg, donc
les nationalistes, ils vont avoir du
mal, hein. Est-ce que ça dépend quand
est-ce que tu cales la France ? Si
j'étais né avant 1939, je serai
allemand. Mais et puis enfin, est-ce que
est-ce que je suis fier d'être en France
? Mais c'est quoi cette question de
merde ?
Alors, question internet, je sais pas.
Je je suis Il y a des choses pour
lesquelles je suis très fier d'être
français. Il y en a il y en a il y en a
d'autres pour lesquelles vraiment j'ai
honte quoi.
Tu es fier d'être français ? Pourquoi ?
La révolution. Merde déjà et pas que
celle de enfin un des principales trucs
que j'ai appris en fac d'histoire et
dont je suis très content que en France
on dit de la révolution 1780 mais il en
a pas eu qu'une. Il y a eu 1815 on a
parlé de Napoléon récemment, il y a eu
1830, il y a eu 1848, il y a eu 1870 à
la commune de Paris, c'est un peu
l'anniversaire aussi et donc ça en fait
quand même plusieurs et donc ouais cette
histoire là, j'en suis vraiment très
fier. Euh quand à un moment je l'ai
étudié, même si j'ai pas eu mon
semestre, j'étais quand même content
d'avoir cravaché pour pour connaître
chaque date de de chaque machin. Quand
est-ce que Zola il était arrivé, quand
est-ce qu'il était parti, qu'est-ce
qu'il avait foutu ? Où est-ce qu'il
avait traîné ? Dans quelle barre il
avait bu. Et euh voilà. Mais non,
était pas fier.
Euh la colonisation,
ça bon, ça c'est facile. Euh
plus récemment,
si tu veux, je peux te fournir des
exemples,
hein,
les ventes d'armes, des choses comme ça.
Non,
je m'y connais pas assez sur ce domaine
et franchement, j'ai envie de dire qui
le fait pas quoi en fait. Alors, on est
un peu des spécialistes, ça c'est sûr,
mais sur le le côté quel pays d'Occident
n'a pas des couilles au cul machin, ça
va être compliqué d'en trouver un, quoi.
Sur quoi je suis pas fier récemment, bah
la politique la politique envers les
migrants enfin en France mais ça mais
c'est la honte absolue. Mais je c'est
pour ça j'ai honte d'être français là.
Je je le dis devant tous les extrémistes
machin pour ça quand on est à
l'étranger, j'ai honte de dire que je
suis français et ça m'arrive de voyager
en Europe. On me demande quand je suis
dans certains pays d'Europe, ouais, tu
viens d'où ? Comme je parle anglais, je
dis ouais, je suis anglais. Parce que
j'ai pas envie qu'on sache que je suis
français. Parce que les gens vont me
regarder genre déjà à l'étranger, les
gens aiment pas trop les français mais
ah ouais mais bon machin parce qu'en ce
moment on pu quoi, faut dire la vérité.
Enfin genre c'est il y a des trucs,
c'est caler ça. Ouais, ça m'a fait honte
à la France. Je n'imaginais pas voir ça
dans mon pays. À un moment, imagine-toi
que tu es dans la jungle de calé au
milieu de l'enfer, indescriptible. C'est
un endroit où il y a aucun sanitaire.
C'est un endroit où il y a trois points
d'eau pour 6000 personnes. C'est un
endroit où calé, c'est le nord de la
France, 90 km/h devant euh 3°, il pleut
du matin au soir. Euh bref, toi tu
reviens de la jungle quand tu marches au
la jungle de calée. Quand on marchait au
milieu, bah c'était un mélange entre des
égouts, des déchets de nourriture de
cuisine, des feux qui machin enfin un
mélange de tout. Mais c'était pas la
faute des migrants si j'avais pas des
goûts quoi en fait tu vois. Donc on
rentrait à l'hôtel avec une espèce de
bout tous nos pantalons et nos
chaussures av couleur jusque là à peu
près. C'était un mélange de merde, de
cuisine, de truc comme ça. On est tombé
balade 15000 fois et cetera. Je sais
plus du tout pourquoi je racontais ça.
Mais
où tu as honte pour la France
le Oui. Et et on rentrait à l'hôtel
recouvert de de merde pour dire pour le
dire franchement. On allait sous la
douche, on mangeait euh normalement et
puis on était tout propre quoi. Mais à 1
km de nous, c'était l'enfer. Et
nous, on était bien dans nos petits
draud à l'hôtel, tu vois, avec la
douche, le robinet et rien que ça,
c'était c'était un luxe. Et pour a mec,
il pay il donnerait cher pour avoir ce
qu'on avait à la chambre d'hôtel. Juste
la douche, juste le petit lavabo, tu
vois. Et ouais, ça vraiment la le ce que
la France a fait et continue de faire
avec les migrants, c'est une honte.
C'est c'est comme l'esclavage. C'est
impardonnable. C'est c'est comme la la
la collaboration, c'est pareil. C'est
c'est aussi grave que ça. C'est le même
niveau. Et j'ai aussi des membres de la
communauté juive dans ma famille. Il y a
cinq religions, donc ça va. Moi, j'en ai
pas. Donc au moins ça quand il a fallu
choisir, ça a été un peu compliqué. Mais
donc je me permets de le dire. Genre la
politique envers les migrants à calé
aujourd'hui même hier, il y a 5 ans,
c'est aussi grave que la collaboration
et ça fait des morts aussi. Et
c'est vraiment Ouais, ça ça me fait
honte franchement. Et je vais y
retourner pour témoigner de ce qui se
passe parce que je ne peux pas continuer
à ne travailler sans témoigner de cette
situation si elle est pas terminée.
Question internet. Quelle est sa vision
de l'avenir de la France dans un
contexte de dérive autoritaires ?
Pens-t-il que nous, Français devrions
être mieux sensibiliser à la notion de
démocratie ? Si oui, comment ?
Tobira, présidente.
Voilà,
je sais pas comment répondre autrement à
la question.
Marine Le Pen, Emmanuel Macron, Éric
Zémour, Philippe Devilier,
Gérald Darmanin, c'est que j'oublie
encore c'est quoi ça ? Il est où le elle
est où la France quoi, justement ? Il y
en a qui parlent de l'honneur d'être
français. Bah là, excuse-moi, quand
j'entends ça, je honte quoi. C'est c'est
c'est euh c'est pas ça la grandeur de la
France quoi. Non, c'est le contraire.
Là, on n'est pas dans la bonne
direction. Donc à un moment Ouais. Non.
Je regrette beaucoup que Christian
Tobira a est abandonné la politique. Je
même journaliste pense que j'aurais
collé des affiches pour elle
franchement.
Alors je vais prendre une dernière
question.
Tu me faire détruire ?
Préparez votre dernière question. Je
vais lui poser une une question avant.
Est-ce que tu as trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ? Hm.
Alors, avec le Covid, on m'a offert
tellement de bouquins que
Tu es vacciné,
hein ?
Tu es vacciné ?
Alors, oui, je suis vacciné.
Les deux injections ?
Pas encore, mais j'ai eu le Covid une
première fois en asymptomatique. Donc,
ça vaut, enfin, c'est comme si j'avais
eu ma mon rappel quand j'ai eu la
première injection, d'après ce que j'ai
compris et euh ça fait 3 semaines en
plus. Donc, normalement pour moi, c'est
bon.
Comment ça se passe les conditions de
garde à vue avec le Covid ?
Ah bah, j'ai pas encore eu de Ah si si,
j'en ai déjà eu trois.
Alors des gardes à vu Covid. Alors au
mois de juin l'année dernière c'était
encore un peu le bordel. Je suis arrivé
avec un FFP3 je crois un comme ça là.
Voilà c'est un peu plus gros qu'un
chirurgical. Et clairement ils avaient
pas l'habitude. Et pour eux j'avais un
FFP3 parce que je voulais me protéger
des gaz lacrymaux. Donc il voulait
absolument m'enlever mon masque avant de
me faire rentrer dans la cellule alors
qu'il y avait déjà quelqu'un.
Il il te fournissait un autre masque
mais ils en avaient pas. Donc je leur ai
dit moi je veux bien enlever mon masque
et rentrer dans la cellule machin mais
vous me donnez un chirurgical au moins
quoi que on va pas se mettre à deux dans
une cellule alors qu'il y a le covid.
Non mais on a pas de chirurgical.
OK dans mon sac poche machin il me
ramène le chir je rentre dans la
cellule. C'était quoi la Oui. Sous
Covid. Et d'ailleurs à ce moment-là, il
y avait Anna Nelson, la photographe de
Taranis, euh mineure au moment des
faits, euh sous Covid, euh en cellule,
fouille au corps, femme.
Euh il y a une plainte en cours, ça
machin mais enfin c'est pour donner
l'ambiance un peu quoi. On avait
strictement rien fait. On a on a été on
a été pris à un contrôle parce qu'on
avait des masques en période Covid. Donc
on est on est ressorti au bout de 4 heur
sans qu'il se soit rien passé parce
qu'il s'était rien passé. Euh, j'ai été
une deuxième fois en garde à vue en
septembre. En gros, à chaque fois que je
venais, là, c'est la première fois où je
viens à Paris, je suis pas en garde à
vue avant une manife, c'est un miracle.
Demain avec Darmanin, je sais pas trop.
Voilà. Mais la deuxième fois, ça s'est
moins bien passé. J'étais tout seul en
fait. Là, ils ont pas apprécié parce que
ils m'ont emmené, ils m'ont arrêté, ils
m'ont emmené dans en garde à vue dans le
commissariat où j'avais été en garde à
vue 48 he pour le doigt d'honneur. Et je
suis arrivé là-bas et je les connais
maintenant et je l'ai je pense que c'est
mutuel, on s'aime pas trop quoi. Et
quand je suis arrivé là-bas, je [__]
je vais mourir quoi. Si je repasse 48 he
là-dedans, ils vont accessirement la
première fois, j'ai fini aux urgences le
dimanche soir, la manif est le samedi
parce qu'il m'avait pas donné à boire
pendant 48h. Donc je suis enfin je vais
pas rentrer dans les détails parce que
c'est une procédure en cours mais je
suis allé aux urgences pour que les
flics appellent les urgences pour un mec
de garde à vue c'est qu'il est pas dans
un très bon état. C'est pour donner une
idée de l'état dans lequel j'étais quoi.
Mais donc j'arrive au commissariat et à
ce moment-là bon bah comme j'avais été
pris un checkpoint mes collègues
savaient pas que j'étais en garde à vue
et j'avais pas moy de les prévenir tu
vois enfin machin et en fait j'avais
encore mon Apple Watch à la main. Je
peux plus c'est une technique c'est
qu'elle est morte maintenant donc je
peux la je peux la cramer quoi. Ils
avaient mon téléphone dans mon sac. Ils
avaient mon sac dans la pièce d'à côté
machin
l'avocat, je suis en garde à vue [__]
je suis au commissariat du 12e et tout
machin. Et et le il y a un flic qui me
voit mais c'était trop tard, j'avais
déjà eu il me fait "OK, c'est bon,
j'arrive l'avocat." Tu vois le fil votre
montre et je je lui donne genre trop
fier tu sais genre et il comprend tu
vois ça a duré mais je sais mais mais 20
secondes. Il est revenu au bout de 20
secondes avec ma montre, mon sac et
direction la voiture. Ils m'ont changé
de commissariat. Je suis arrivé dans
l'autre commissariat là, il rigolait
plus du tout. trois mecs là la la
cellule fouille au corps direct. Ils
m'ont foutu en caleçon. Ils ont vidé
avec les photos de mon petit frère. Ils
m'ont fait ils m'ont enlevé le caleçon.
Bon, je pas j'ai pas du tout c'est comme
en prison et cetera, mais ils m'ont
quand même fait faire un un tourniqu à
poil. Si tu veux, c'est ce qui était
drôle, c'est que justement, ils ont vu
mes blessures des grenades quand ils
m'ont foutu à poil. Euh, ils ont vu à ce
moment-là, c'était encore frais. Donc,
enfin, non, mais le mec, ils ont un
détecteur de métal quand tu es à poil.
Ce que je enfin non, il passe les
détecteurs de métal puis il te mettent à
poil. Et pour rigoler avec le gars, je
fais "Bah, j'ai encore des éclats
métalliques de vos grenades de merde
dans la cuisse. Regarde si ça sonne avec
ton détecteur." Il il y a trois flics,
je suis tout seul avec eux, je suis à
poil. Je lui dis ça, le mec il est là
mais ça l'a perturbé tu vois. Mais il a
quand même essayé du coup et il passait
et ça a pas bipé et me fait "Bah non, il
y a rien." Je fais "Bus, votre
détecteur, il est pas assez sensible."
Et ça l'a tellement perturbé que j'en ai
rien à [__] d'être à poil et que je
sois concentré sur les les éclats. Fait
bon bah rabillez-vous en fait. Et puis
voilà, cellule 10 minutes, je me suis
allongé, j'ai fait la sieste. Euh il m'a
cherché pour le l'OPJ. Euh oui, alors
voilà judiciaire
euh officiel du police judiciaire. Alors
mais j'étais blasé, lui était blasé
aussi. J'arrive, je sors de la cellule,
c'était l'officier de policaire de
l'autre commissariat. Donc lui, il me
connaissait pas. Il savait pas pourquoi
j'avais arrêté, il avait rien contre moi
particulièrement. Et et j'arrive et je
fais bon qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que ça va
être maintenant ? Qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait encore ? fait "Écoutez monsieur,
moi ça me fait encore plus chier que
vous que vous soyez là parce que j'ai au
moins 50 papiers à remplir juste parce
que vous allez sortir." Genre le gars,
il avait un truc comme ça à remplir
juste parce que j'étais passé dans son
comico et que j'avais j'avais un truc de
me enf ça le faisait chier de s'occuper
de moi pendant 3 heures. Donc il me fait
"Vous allez répondre aux questions ?"
Non. "Bon d'accord. Alors je les pose
pas, c'est plus simple, on va gagner du
temps. Et puis je suis sorti mais pour
quand même qu'il perd pas la face, ils
ont gardé mes protèges tibia.
C'est tout.
Question internet.
de Yoda. À force de vous faire mver de
manifestants,
pouvez-vous comme journaliste réellement
rester objectif ?
Bah, il faudrait préciser la question.
En quoi on n'est pas objectif ? parce
que euh en manif, tu vois mes images, tu
m'entends assez rarement, sauf quand je
pose des questions. Euh je vois pas en
quoi je suis moins objectif en publiant
40 minutes de rush d'une manife sans
commentaire qu'un reportage sur la même
manife de BFM télé qui dure 45 secondes
avec un commentaire qui te dit quoi
regarder dans les images que tu as vu.
Ça répond à la question ou
c'est ta réponse ? Question de MOA 936
sur la destruction parsale armée
israélienne de l'immeuble des médias sur
Gaza. Est-ce que un commentaire
c'est pas acceptable ? C'est je vois pas
de quel pays dans le monde on
accepterait ça. Enfin c'est c'est ça n'a
rien à voir avec le conflit
israélo-palestinien. Ça n'a rien à voir
avec Israël. Ça n'a rien à voir avec la
Palestine. Ça à voir avec le droit
international de la guerre.
On ne touche pas au journaliste.
Je sais qu'en France c'est compliqué
parce que même la police française l'a
pas encore totalement compris voire même
pas du tout. Mais
si la police l'armée américaine avait
fait ça à Bagdad en 91, il se serait
passé quoi ? Mais
ils ont pas fait ça en Serbie.
Euh je ça me dit rien. Mais imaginons
je remets 9 en direct avec les caméras
infrarouges et tout. Bim ! Il Non, enfin
même si même la méthode les prévenir
avant, d'accord, au final, ils ont quand
même pulvérisé le bâtiment avec toutes
les archives, tout le matériel. Enfin,
c'est c'est pas possible. Si si on
accepte ça d'un pays, quel qu'il soit,
alors un autre peut le faire. Alors un
autre peut se dire que il a la
légitimité de le faire. Et ça c'est pas
possible. Non. Euh s y a pas de
journaliste dans une guerre, on sait pas
ce qui se passe parce que il y a que la
propagande et à un moment ça a été
extrêmement compliqué. D'ailleurs, ça
toujours les Français journalistes ou
même pour les étrangers de filmer la
guerre au Sahel. Combien d'images de
journalistes indépendants on a de la
guerre au Sahel ? Pein ! Il y a rien.
Les seules images que vous avez, c'est
que des images qui sont tournées en bê
avec les militaires uniquement. Alors
après c'est pas c'est pas un terrain qui
est facile en B. Ça veut dire c'est un
un tour de touristes où ils emmènent les
journalistes. C'est ça. En en beded,
c'est ça ?
Oui. Donc euh avec les avec les
militaires. Mais si tu veux, il y a il y
a pas d'indépendant qui peut et même la
zone étant interdite à la presse, les
militaires, ils captent le moins de son,
ils le chopent, il il le ramènent à
Bamako et ils le mettent dans l'avion,
quoi. Donc à un moment euh non ça c'est
pas acceptable non plus. Tu vois, je le
mets au même niveau que la destruc.
Enfin non mais c'est c'est tout aussi
grave de s'attaquer à la presse en
l'empêchant de faire son travail sur le
terrain
au Mali que à Gaza que en Chine sur les
Wigour et cetera. C'est pareil. C'est on
peut pas à un moment euh dire,
"Regardez, on peut pas faire du travail
de jour sur les gours en Chine" et euh
après dire "Mais c'est normal que que
qu' bombarde le bâtiment de la FP euh à
Gaza." Non, enfin de de la paix à Gaza,
c'est c'est non
je vois je je comprends pas je ne vois
pas par quel bia on peut tolérer ça et
de la part de qui en fait. Quel que soit
le pays, quel que soit le conflit, quel
que soit voilà surtout pas dans une
période comme aujourd'hui où les médias
ont une telle importance, où les réseaux
sociaux ont une telle importance, où la
guerre se fait presque aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux, euh c'est le moment où
on a encore plus besoin de médias. Donc
non, là en fait c'est aussi grave que le
bâtiment a été détruit que le fait que
les journalistes extérieurs ne puissent
pas accéder à la bande de Gaza. C'est
pas normal non plus. OK, c'est un
conflit, OK, c'est dangereux, mais ces
journalistes décident de prendre le
risque d'être sous les bombes, c'est
leur job. Euh
voilà, je je c'est je connais pas ce
conflit, je le maîtrise pas et je me
permettrai pas d'en parler. Par exemple,
je comprends pourquoi est-ce que les
gens ils peuvent pas passer par la
frontière jordanienne qui a aussi avec
la bande de Gaza. Euh je je maîtrise pas
du tout le sujet donc j'ai pas envie de
dire une connerie mais concrètement quel
que soit le conflit,
on n'interdit pas les journalistes, on
les attaque pas. En France, on leur
balance pas des grenades. En Israël, on
tire pas sur leur bâtiment, quoi. C'est
pareil. C'est la même chose.
Trois bouquins à conseiller à notre
communauté.
Il faut que tu parles plus fort de
trois livres à conseiller à notre
communauté.
Dans tous les livres que j'ai lu en ce
moment. Je pense que les gens devraient
relire la peste de Camu
euh
le chemin des dames aussi hein.
C'est un peu tard maintenant, il aurait
fallu le lire un peu avant la la
deuxième vague mais c'est intéressant
parce que c'est assez vieux et mais en
même temps c'est tellement contemporain
avec ce qui est en train de se passer et
euh et puis c'est aussi un livre qu'on a
tous lu à l'école et du coup on l'a un
peu tous en tête par morceau et de le
relire aujourd'hui en pleine pandémie
c'est super intéressant. Ça provoque des
espèces de reconnexion. Moi, j'ai bien
aimé relire la peste de Camu derrière
étant. Euh, je conseillerai un livre de
Hugo Melkior euh comme le roi Mage, un
autre un autre roi Mage, un ancien
copain de Ren 2 d'ailleurs. [__] j'ai
oublié le titre de son livre, il va me
détruire. Euh
c'est un il est euh prof d'histoire à
l'université R. On était étudiant
ensemble et il a fait une un bouquin de
recherche sociologique sur mouvement
social et l'université Rané aux années
70. euh Ren 2 qui a toujours été un peu
leader à gauche et cetera et c'est une
c'est une étude historique et
sociologique sur un mouvement social
entre je crois que c'est en 72 74, je
sais plus exactement sur quoi c'est mais
c'est intéressant parce que c'est l'âge
de mes parents ou même euh enfin c'est
c'est ça remonte à quand même un petit
moment et on a oublié cette période en
fait les mouvements sociaux des années
70 on se souvient très bien de Caron les
années 68 con bendit et cetera, mais
moins des années 70 et du coup il a il a
beaucoup documenté ce moment et je
trouve ça super intéressant. J'ai
vraiment aimé lire son bouquin. Le
troisième euh alors là je me euh
le titre quelle horreur
c'est une étude sur
la psychiatrie aux États-Unis au moment
des civil rights du du d'entre les
années entre les années 40 et les années
70.
Je peux tricher ? Merci.
Excellent bouquin. Également, un bouquin
d'histoire.
Euh,
pardon pour le live.
D'ailleurs, j'en profite pour dire à
ceux qui nous écoutent en podcast de pas
oublier de nous soutenir sur Tipi euh
parce que comme il voit passer le petit
bordeaux, on on le rappelle.
Tu as trouvé ?
Je l'ai.
Étouffer la révolte de Johann Metzel, la
psychiatrie contre les Civil Whites, une
histoire du contrôle social. Ah, je suis
tombé amoureux de ce livre. Prévoyez un
mois pour le lire, mais
c'est extrêmement intéressant
parce que c'est pas que c'est
contemporain, mais ça permet de
comprendre un certain nombre de choses.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose d'impérissable qui va
rester sur les réseaux si YouTube
dégage pas la nouvelle génération vidéo.
Ouais.
Que je lui dirai de faire ou que
un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Un conseil.
Déjà, est-ce qu'on peut leur donner des
conseils ?
[__] baladez-vous en forêt quoi.
Lâchez les téléphones, lâchez les écrans
de temps en temps quoi. Allez, sortez
marcher dehors, genre sortez. Je j'ai
deux petits frères, donc je vois à peu
près qui sont bien décalés, mais
décrochez quoi. Mettez vos pieds dans
l'eau quoi. Allez camper dans la forêt,
faites du snowboard mais pensez pensez à
vivre. Le Covid c'est bientôt fini.
Enfin, j'espère. Mais oui, c'est on le
souhaite tous. Mais ouais, oubliez pas
que ouais, la période des canapés est
bientôt finie, quoi. Donc allez-y,
profitez-en quoi. Sortez, quoi. Genre
vivez dehors, pas dedans. C'est c'est
quand je vois les jeunes générations,
c'est le premier truc que j'ai envie de
leur dire quoi. Euh,
faites de la musique, faites dessiner,
faites de la trottinette si vous avez
envie, mais sortez.
Gaspar Glanz, merci.
Merci à toi pour l'invitation. Merci
beaucoup.
[Musique]